Joe Biden stated that he's seen and
confirmed that children have been
beheaded in in Israel following the
terror attack by Hamas there are still
many people who are skeptical and I
think that's still fair but at this
point we have CBS news saying that
they've gotten word from emergency First
Responders in Israel and uh Joe Biden is
making this claim it is still entirely
possible just look I I remain skeptical
skeptical but uh uh I mean it's it's
it's it's it's tough right we saw what
they did we've I watched another video
today of of Hamas killing civilians
these videos they exist you can watch
them well certainly some of these videos
are probably fake and repurposed there
are some that are undeniable so when you
hear that uh children have had their
heads
removed I mean the challenge is it's
like it's it's more believable than any
claim we've heard in a long time now
with Joe Biden saying it I'm not about
to start believing Joe Biden or the
mainstream press so the only thing I I
can say to this is take it for what you
will you decide what you think is or
isn't and that's the best we can do
until we have some kind of hard evidence
this is what we've got we also have one
of the uh leaders and fighters of Hamas
calling for Global Jihad on Friday
calling on people to uh to make it to
attack uh Target Jewish people to Target
Israel and so I hope everybody is just
uh uh paying attention you know got you
don't got to be paranoid but but paying
attention because it's getting serious
with the stuff it's kind of freaky so
we're going to talk about that before we
get started my friends head over to cast
brew.com click the link in the
description below and pick up some cast
brew coffee when you buy cast Brew
Coffee you are supporting our show and
getting the best coffee you'll ever have
I swear it's the best my favorite is
appalachin kns but of course everybody
loves rise with Roberto Jr it's our
light roast and it sells better than all
the rest but I know it's just because
Roberto Jr's on the bag and everybody
keeps asking for rbj but we'll probably
come out with an rb3 Roberto Jr's son
he'll get a blend soon and then for
Halloween we have rise with Roberto Jr
because as many of you know Roberto Jr
had a heart attack and died suddenly
just this past month and so in his
memory and as a joke we're making the
zombie blend for Halloween which will be
coming soon and a limited time only so
support the show buy Casper coffee but
also go to Tim cast.com click join us
become a M if you'd like to support our
work directly if you like the work we do
if you think the message we spread is a
good message we need your support your
membership is basically how we make this
machine run and as a member you get
access to our Discord server where you
can hang out with like-minded
individuals share ideas work on projects
they are running their own shows early
morning shows pre-shows after shows and
when you join the Discord as a member
you can submit questions so our you you
can call into our uncensored membersonly
show Monday through Thursday we're going
to have an uncensored show coming up for
you at 10: p.m. tonight you don't want
to miss it so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is chadmore hey great to be
here thanks for having me on yeah who
are you what do you do uh I'm an author
I'm uh hawk in my book Tucker which is
the the official biography of Tucker
Carlson which just came out in August
and I uh was almost done with the book
when his show was taken off the air so
we actually pushed back publication
updated of the book I spent you know
last year working on this hanging out
with him I was regular on his show which
is how I knew him and um everyone seems
to be really enjoying it uh and um yeah
that's basically me I'm also a
contributing editor at The Spectator as
well right on well uh glad to have you
we also got Hannah Clair brimo hanging
out hey I'm Han Clair brimo I'm a writer
for
timcast.net when you were writing that
book did you write about when John
Stewart went on CrossFire was it man
that was transformative for Tucker I
watched it in real time I think it was
the moment it happened it was like it
was like humiliating but also he took it
seriously cuz you could tell he had a
respect for joh and like he became like
a Pioneer for justice after that it was
incredible John Stewart did no Tucker
tuck Tucker like he started to step away
from the mainstream and was like maybe
this warmongering isn't necessarily the
right way and he he started to think for
himself after that it was really
powerful so behind the scenes John
Stewart he went on that show and he
lambasted Tucker Carlson and his co-host
saying Crossfire is bad for America it's
just you pundits going back and forth
and uh and then as soon as and and they
say it killed the show Crossfire
Crossfire was taken off the air after
that all of America was siding with John
Stewart yes we hate this fighting I mean
look at us now right yeah after the
cameras stopped rolling John Stewart who
was there to promote his book said to
them um you know I miss came to town and
he trashed you guys and got four new
station so I think this worked out well
for me it was all planned and then John
student when the other guy was um
Tucker's co-host whose name slipped my
mind right now um wouldn't take John Su
wouldn't take any their calls after that
he's a total nasty wow Tu I got all that
in the book yeah I put all that stuff in
the book we'll talk more about it yeah
we'll get Tucker and John Stewart in the
room together that'll be like John would
take my call either when I want to
interview him Serge we got Serge on my
right what's happening Brother yeah I'm
here I'm excited for another exciting
episode of timcast let's get to it
here's the story from the New York Post
Biden says he's seen confirmed pictures
of terrorists beheading children in
Israel President Biden said on Wednesday
that he has seen confirmed pictures of
terrorists uh beheading children in
southern Israel following initial
reports that to 40 babies were butchered
over the weekend in homes near the Hamas
ruled Gaza Strip quote I never really
thought I would see and have confirmed
pictures of terrorists beheading
children I never thought I'd ever anyway
that's one way to end that statement I
think we actually have the clip uh not
here but uh here let's play this one I
mean I I I've been doing this a long
time I never really thought that I would
see and have
confirmed picture pictures of
terrorists beheading
children I never thought I'd
ever anyway I uh but there
are countries in the region that are
trying to be of some help including Arab
Nations now still with this I'm not I
I'm not absolutely convinced and and the
issue is one I'm not about to start
believing Joe Biden the D disc corrupt
as they come there are special interests
that want war in the Middle East the
these people despise Donald Trump and
one of the strongest re one of the
biggest reasons is that Donald Trump was
trying to bring peace to the Middle East
Donald Trump was trying to remove you as
involvement when when we talk about how
Russia did not invade Ukraine under the
Trump Administration they say yeah it's
because Trump was serving Vladimir Putin
I'm like yeah I mean maybe it's because
Donald Trump was like this is none of
our business we should stop supporting
these these these Terror groups whether
directly or indirectly we should stop
invading these countries for oil and
mind our own business and Russia was
like well if you're not pressing on our
borders we're not you know we've got no
reason to fight they get Trump out they
come in and it's War it's conflict its
expansion and so this this narrative is
extremely shocking based on the videos
I've seen it's it's it's unfortunately
whether whether you want to accept it or
not it's easy to believe they did this
right that's the scary thing well they
also thought Trump was a lunatic yeah
they thought he was a loose cannon they
had no idea there was some meeting that
actually Tucker told me this story
working on this that Trump leaned over
to Vladimir Putin and said if you invade
Russ if you invade Ukraine when I'm
president I will nuke this out of
Moscow and Putin believed him and nobody
wanted to mess with Trump they thought
he was a total loose canon which of
course I don't think he was at all but
that I think is a good a good impr it
was a bad image to have it was not a bad
image to have you kind of want the rest
of the world especially your enemies to
think that about your leader for sure
yeah for sure they don't want to be able
to predict you I mean the the problem
right now is that the loss of life is
always tragic violence is obviously
detestable but Joe Biden is not a
trustworthy president and so it is hard
to believe anything that would come out
of his administration even if it is
something awful like this you don't want
to believe they would lie about being
able to confirm this on the other hand
you just can't trust them look at
everything they've lied about that's
yeah and again we've mentioned horri the
near year testimony from 1990 that got
us into the first Gulf War I don't like
the way he said the word confirmed in
that speech he said the these pictures
I've seen confirmed like it was like um
he was dropping the word like they they
talking points make sure you say the
word confirmed when you talk about this
I said yesterday prepare for deep fake
that we're in another mod This Modern
War it's going to be technology you've
never seen before utilized and when they
tell you some something happened and
then some days later you're going to
start to see blurry images or images be
wary don't snap to emotions well there's
here's a really funny one Don Jr posted
a video it is extremely graphic it is
brutal and it is of Israeli civilians
being killed by Hamas Community
notes were placed on it saying old video
and fake because a pro Palestinian
activist uh posted a screenshot of a CLI
a thumbnail of the video over and over
again with the date of 2016 or something
like that but it is believed now that
that was fake and the video is real and
now wired has contacted the government
and done a deeper analysis on on I guess
the metadata and the video and found
Donald Trump Jr was correct the video
was from Israel and it appears that
activists are trying to make fake
screenshots to trick people into
thinking they're fake yo we are in a
whole new world of information Warfare
it's entirely possible that wired got
bunk information from the government to
convince us the videos are real who
knows what do you but but I I will I
will defer to if you've got the Biden
Administration and Donald Trump Jr and
like everyone's kind of like yeah this
is probably
true I think you're going to have to go
with that right if if people who
absolutely despise each other are like I
you know this one this is real then yeah
if both Waring parties are agreeing on
it then well it doesn't seem farfetched
from what we know about this group of
people like nobody thinks this isn't
something they wouldn't do you know
there there are undeniable videos yeah
right so there there are videos where
it's like I don't know what this is
right it's a guy and is like running
through a field and I'm like the video
that Don junr posted was tough it's like
people in a room being shot and I'm like
man that's brutal but then there are
videos that are very easily and
discernably of Southern Israel at an
event where you can corroborate the
pictures of the music festival and
you're watching people be shot and it's
just like this happened like we know
these videos are real that's the easy
thing where it's like the story of of
these babies being killed beheaded you
don't need it Hamas did it and not only
that mad respect to Max Blumenthal
coming on the show and talking about
he's more Pro Palestine but he outright
said hamas's strategy is to Target as
many civilians as possible to use his
bargaining chips for against Israel they
are kidnapping civilians that's their
tactic he called it a target of
opportunity and I'm like make no mistake
this is not in dispute we we know what
they're
doing I was thinking you know it's
horrible it is absolutely I mean it's
one of the most horrific things you do
to kill somebody and to kill a small
child is like the most horrific thing
but like what's more horrific if if
someone cuts off the head of a baby or
if someone blows up six babies with a
bomb yeah yeah Tim's right like you
don't need it they don't need this to
sell the case so the the rational for
faking it doesn't make any much sense
right and and the other thing too uh I
think it was it was you know there were
a lot of people that were critical of
Max Blumenthal because he does have a
more prop Palestinian stance but he
knows a lot about this and he actually
pushed back on some of there there's a
conspiracy theory going around that
Israel knew this was going to happen and
a lot of people are pushing at some
prominent personalities saying that they
knew it was going to happen they let it
happen because now they can use as an
excuse to go into Gaza and do all of
this stuff and bomb them and Max was
like no way absolutely not he was he
said Israel uh uh was humiliated there
uh uh many there there's a lot of
private uh technology and security firms
in Israel that Pride themselves on being
the best and this is true because I've
covered this stuff going back 10 years
with occupy there are many surveillance
compan that are born out of Israel that
are like we're the best Israel proves it
this is is extremely bad for for these
for for the uh this sector the security
sector and he also wanted to mention
things I don't want to I don't want to
uh comment too much on because I'm not
the expert on it but the the military
doctrine that Israel has in in terms of
captured IDF soldiers is so extreme he
said Israel would never allow one of
their soldiers to be captured I mean the
idea that they let this happen is just
there's no way yeah and that's that he's
Pro he's more Pro Palestine I mean I
think I find it interesting I think the
big problem is going to be the Deluge of
information especially fighting war in
the technology age right we're going to
have videos that surface from wherever
we're already seeing that Community
notes are they're they're finding ways
to work around these potential
safeguards that we have uh the thing
that I saw a lot today was parents
warning or parents groups warning
parents to have their kids delete Tik
Tok and all their social media platforms
while this goes on because it's
permeating through all the algorithm so
you having young teenagers seeing very
violent images and of course that's
deeply serving on the on the other hand
if you're cutting all kinds of people
off from information not that teenagers
should see violence it starts to get
very dystopian right we don't know
what's real and we don't know who should
be seeing it we don't know where to stop
it from coming from man the community
notes thing I think was obvious it is
good that you have these Community notes
because some of these things are very
easily and provably false but I have
seen on more than one occasion people
manipulate Community notes it's it's
basically if enough people say something
is true they'll just run with it m and
then you end up with Community notes
that are like unre related to the tweets
or in this instance someone made what
appears I I guess the story would be
this guy's screenshot was fake to trick
people it's remarkable Don Jr posts a
video and then some guy posts some
screenshot of with with no website
address it's a pictures of thumbnails
with a date on it and that was enough
for people on community notes to say
Donald Trump's posting fake news I mean
amazing is community notes any better
than Wikipedia right Wikipedia can be
edited and Wikipedia self-censor so we
don't really know what information is
provable there's AAS reason we tell high
schoolers you can't cite Wikipedia or
maybe Community notes in your term
papers uh it's all you got to follow the
sources and the interesting thing was
that the source on this community note
was some guy's tweet and then and now
people are responding to John Jr being
like wire did a a deep analysis on the
video and found the source and said it's
real like it was recorded here here's
all the confirmation it's crazy
apparently there are like other angles
or something I don't know well I and
especially in Don Junior's case I'm sure
they want Don Jr to look like he is
promoting something crazy because of his
last name you know it's sort of a trap
from the beginning for him yeah or but
wed was forced to defend
him they did not like no thank you yeah
uh we were talking about this before the
show that it's there's a lot of um
people who thought they were on the same
side who are now realizing perhaps they
are not when it comes to this issue and
I think that's going to be uh maybe a I
I obviously I don't want to be born on
you know the backs of death and violence
but on the other hand reconciling that
it's not just the two sides no one has
any Lan of compromise is sort of a hard
thing to put American culture through
it's just so hard to believe cuz we've
always known I guess like you're talking
about like BLM and antifa we've always
known that about them we've always known
that about the college left that they
were super super pro Palestine violence
be damned but I don't think left
realized it I mean I'm maybe not the one
to ask but I think I think because I had
known people who would come out as you
know I I have Jewish friends who have
come out as Pro Palestine years and
years before and it would really shock
their community and I found that
interesting uh it's not something that I
would necessarily have a personal
ability to comment on but I think there
is more division than they realize
because they especially the progressive
left is used to being a unified front
all the time yeah let's uh let's let's
let's talk about black lives matter we
have this from ABC News BLM Chicago
backs Palestine after Hamas Terror
invasion of Israel and this is causing a
major backlash and uh tons of Democrats
are now disavowing black lives matter
this is going to be a huge break in the
the culture War because now you've got
Democrats who are like wait a minute you
mean the farle we've supported want
Israelis to be killed yeah take a look
at this tweet this is an archive it was
deleted from BLM Chicago it says that is
all that is it and it says I stand with
Palestine and it's a it's a paraglider
with a Palestinian flag the paragliders
are the ones who went into the music
festival and started killing civilians
they did more than just kill they they
right kidna raped kidnapped uh children
and so this is this is an image
explicitly supporting the tactic of
targeting civilians look man we we sit
here and we complain about war all day
and when the US has collateral damage We
complain about it we support Julian
Assange he released collateral murder we
see we see these these war crimes we
criticize Obama we criticize Trump
killing civilians is wrong Israel kills
a who say it's wrong the the issue
however is in the instance of Israel
often times what they're saying is
they've built a weapons Depot and a
military base under a hospital we've
given them a warning and we're going to
take it out I say okay do I take
Israel's word for it well the one thing
I can say is Israel at least is saying
that much we are trying to avoid killing
civilians well okay I don't trust
governments right everyone's got an
agenda but I can accept that you then
have Barack Obama's ridiculous nonsense
excuse for killing an American citizen
in Yemen they've never answered for and
that's evil but this is overtly
celebrating the tactic of targeting
civilians intentionally yeah you know
that's black lives matter Max Blumenthal
he was on last night and he said that
these guys were paratrooping into to hit
a military Target and landed next to the
Target in the music festival and it was
an attack of opportunity as opposed to a
target a target of opportunity I don't
know if it really I don't know how much
matters wait wait like I mean if he's
being factual he's being factual yes but
in terms of of celebrating it still I
mean that image now is still the image
of attacking civilians at a music
festival it's you know the wind blew the
wrong way we actually when they made
this image they knew what they were and
they kept it up for hours it wasn't like
oops 20,000 comments or something before
they they decided someone decided to
take it down what I want to be careful
of is you know people were being
critical of Max yesterday they're like
oh I can't believe he would downplay no
no no hold on if it is a fact that that
Hamas was intending to Target military
bases that would make sense they say we
want to hit military bases and then as
they're coming through the sky they say
Hey look Ians let's get them because it
is a known tactic to Target civilians to
use his bargaining chips against Israel
Max said all that too those are facts
accept them it it proves definitively or
I should say a journalist with a pro
with a pro palestin bias explicitly told
us their strategy is Target civilians
why why why would they attack an Israeli
military base on parag I mean the IDF is
scary he going toin well what he was
saying is that it caught him off guard
and it was humil
it was quiet off radar cuz it's they're
so low to the ground and no heat
probably yeah I what I find fascinating
in the whole thing is that there are
many people prominent individuals many
who are very critical of Israel PL
saying that Israel knew this was coming
and let it happen and then you have Max
of all people who is you know much more
opposed to Israel's actions being like
no there's no way Israel knew in advance
they were humiliated by this Hamas was
targeting the mil the military bases and
the music festival was nearby and so it
became a target of opportunity for them
because it a known tactic they Ed wow
but that wasn't the only place that was
attacked right they went to a bunch of
villages bunch of beaches anywhere makes
me think that their primary target was
take out the military perimeter and then
with a secondary Target of get as many
civilians as you can it's evil and and
and this is the this is the problem
right I don't like War I don't like the
conflict I don't like hearing about
children dying in Gaza they're all these
tweets coming out the far left saying oh
look all these innocent civilians I'm
like yeah it's all bad it's all bad dude
but
yo ask I I can ask this question of
anyone and you're going to get the same
answer the pro the pro Palestine side
knows what the answer to this question
is and they will try to avoid answering
it what would happen to Israel if they
removed all of the security fencing
around Gaza and said free movement for
all within Gaza into Israel what would
happen oh we know exactly what happened
we watched it Happ we watch we watched
what happened when they tore the fences
down yeah there there there's no
question about that and so you know you
talk to someone who's po Palestine and
they're going to say well I mean you
know it's like oh we we get it this is
the problem you complain about what
Israel is doing in Gaza but what's the
answer well these people are in their
prison I'm like yeah and if they open
the doors it would be Bloodshed it would
be murder it would be massacres it would
be it would be War it would be you know
they they weal a lot of people talk
about 1948 and how it was wrong for you
know Israelis to push Palestinians off
their land and I'm just like it's War I
don't have a good answer for you man war
is bad it sucks but the answer today is
not to just make the war worse that see
seems to be what Hamas wants to do but
anyway back to the point like otherwise
we're going to go in circles back to
what black lives matter represents we
also have a Democratic Socialist member
of Congress he has quit the DSA and
denounced them for their support of of
of all of this who who was it uh let me
let me let me pul up his name do you
guys know his name I had his uh Jamal
Bowman no was he part of the DSA Shri
here we go we got it Shri thodar
Congressman he renounces he's a let's
see proud detroiter yeah from Michigan
Michigan's 13 district and he renounces
his membership in the DSA saying today
I'm officially renouncing my membership
in the DSA after the brutal terar
attacks in Israel which included the
indiscriminate murder rape and
kidnapping of innocent men women and
children I can no longer associate with
an organization unwilling to call out
Terror in all its forms Sunday's hate
filled and anti-semitic rally in New
York City promoted by the New York DSA
makes it impossible for me to continue
my affiliation I stand with Israel and
its right to defend it self there is no
place for moral equivocation in the face
of unadulterated evil as we have seen
from Hamas I will continue to work
towards the goals that brought me to
Congress in the first place universal
healthcare workers rights strong labor
union equity for communities of color
environmental justice and compassion
immigration my ideals have not changed
at all I strongly believe that ending my
association with the DSA serves my
constituents interests as they expect me
to represent them by helping to build a
better more just world not Fanning the
Flames of hatred shout out to Ryan long
who put out a video called the actor
doesn't know whether to support
Palestine or Israel
because the fascinating thing is what
we're seeing here with Shri and there's
another story about a bunch of Harvard
students who are being blacklisted and
now they're putting out letters being
like no we don't support Palestine we're
so sorry we're so sorry the default
position for for a lot of these people
was whatever the narrative is I support
whatever popular thing is black lives
matter was current thing we support it
uhoh BLM not just BLM in Chicago but La
came out in defense of what Hamas did
yeah and now if you tweet in support of
BLM you will get canceled these people
don't have convictions don't have morals
and were marching in lock step with what
they thought was the power structure
that meant when atrocities occurred with
on video and we see innocent people
being praed around murdered kidnapped
Etc they ignore that and say it doesn't
matter BLM is popular thing think about
that just I want to reiterate that
because that is that ex that explains
the culture War so well for all of us we
can sit here and be like man it's really
bad when civilians died no matter who
does it right what Hamas did is
horrifying and it's atrocious we don't
want war I'm skeptical of these videos
and these stories did babies really get
beheaded man this is tough we try to be
reasonable So many actors members of
Congress Harvard students knowing these
videos emerged thought but the left is
in power so I will just agree with
whatever they say and what happened
major backlash big regular people were
like bro you just defended literal
Terror attacks on innocent civilians the
problem with people that are obsessed
with domestic politics and have no idea
what's going on geopolitically you got
to know both well speak and I think in
this case it's important to note that
black lives matter is essentially saying
the tacus H hamamasu are Justified right
if you have a political movement within
the or within the United States that
says essentially using civilians as
pawns harming them to get your political
ends is is worth doing that is a very
significant statement to take right we
know the black lives matter movements
often end in riots rots and violence the
fact that they're lining up behind this
kind of action is something we should
all be extremely wary of yeah they share
violent means to an end philosophy
although right and they're confirming it
on a geopolitical stage now of course
yeah I'm just saying they got passed off
as being the so we're peaceful peaceful
movement and I think Tim's totally right
ultimately you know people don't know
enough about these issues to be able to
say definitively how they feel about it
but they know they're supposed to say
something that's why Ryan Ryan Long's
fun video is so is so funny he knows
he's supposed to take a stand he doesn't
know what it is because he takes his
cues from everyone around him they the
issue is they don't care that many of
the people who are who are waving BLM
flags and these progress Pride Flags
don't know don't care all they're really
saying is I support what we view to be
the cultural and institutional power and
so when the institutional powers do evil
things these people march in lockstep
behind them and that's what we talk
about I I've mentioned that the progress
pride flag is is is akin to the Nazi
flag not in that it represents the same
ideology but that it represents people
blindly marching behind what they view
to be power this shattered that and now
people are panicking I love this this
Harvard student organization being like
we never meant this no we're so we we
regret signing this letter in support of
Palestine money cuz we'll get our six
figure jobs when we graduate that's
right because now they're they're
realizing they're getting canceled right
the the only thing they ever cared about
was looking like they fit in no morals
and no principles but there's also I
agree with you but there's also I mean
there's this ethos in the white Liber
I'll say white liberal but culturally
white you know the Western liberal I
think you were touching on this too when
they're they're suddenly horrified it's
this mentality and it's so racist I know
that word so overused but it exposes how
extremely racist they are that they look
at people like Islamic terrorists and
it's the same way they look at inner
city violence in Black communities and
they think uh and they look at Israel
like Israel is a civilized country so we
hold them to a higher moral standard we
hold them to our moral standards these
third world people they're stupid uh
they're look at their skin colors look
how they live we can't expect them to
behave how we behave and they're so
oppressed so we can't you know we can't
Israel is hold held to a different
standard they cannot behave like this
these people they just don't know any
better and we have to be their
custodians we have to stand up for them
it's deeply that is the the liberal
ethos so much and but then you have the
more violent Wing like BLM and antifa
that actually are like no we want to see
dead bodies and we hate you know these
people we want communism now no it's
it's crazy but the polite Progressive
class that's exactly what it is and now
they're having this moral crisis of what
side to I think that they're going to
have a really hard time reconciling this
I think when people want to do uh the
right thing they but they don't actually
think about the issues just think about
what their friends are doing they have
no moral compass I mean with these
Harvard students you know if they really
believed in what they said they wouldn't
have backed down nothing nothing should
be worth compromising your values for
but it's not about values it's about
signaling that they have done the right
things it reminds me of you know and
it's it's a terrible comparison to draw
but it reminds me of all of the um
people who suddenly became excited about
various causes is like uh after uh the
Parkland shooting all these students who
were suddenly deeply involved in gun
violence and they would hold protests
and whatever else and then they would
get into Elite colleges because they
were signaling that they were behind the
right thing all the time I mean that's
how we got David hog yes uh and to what
end what are what are we doing to better
serve the the values of the community
maybe they really stand by it but
ultimately it was a thing that they
thought would level would help them get
an advantage moving forward yeah of
course like corporations virtue
signaling same thing well this is the
thing we have to do now yeah I think uh
one of the challenging things coming out
of Israel is just going to be the fact
that so much I know I said this earlier
but there's going to be so much
information and so much visual media
that there are going to be people who
knee-jerk take a strong stance who then
are going to back down and change their
mind and I again with this Congressman I
think that's a very solid move to
renounce an organization that you have
been a part of and at one point would
have served you to say oh yeah I'm a DSA
member look how trendy and Progressive I
am yeah I want to pull up this story
from wired a graphic Hamas video Donald
Trump Jr shared on is actually real
research confirms a video posted by
Donald Trump Jr showing Hamas militants
attacking Israelis was falsely flagged
in a community note as being years old
thus making X's disinformation problem
worse and not better the first thing I
say is um many of these liberal
journalists are really upset that Elon
Musk is doing so well so any opportunity
to attack X is an opportunity they will
take but in this instance it actually
ends up working out Trump Jr is being
defended they're in a weird position
where it's like well you know I guess I
guess defending Trump Jr who's
criticizing terror is the lesser of two
evils or whatever in their mind as
leftists starting to be as grudgingly
the ler of two people maybe defending
each other as Americans might be the
right way forward this our weird healing
moment so they just to the story here
and what I want to get into with this is
it's it's all fake news and all
manipulation right somebody I I'm not
going to play the video it is it is
beyond graphic it is it not can you give
a summary of what it was yeah it's a
bunch of bodies on the ground being shot
there there's it's graphic just
understand it is just I I I I don't even
want to describe it yeah it's people
dying and they're and you're watching it
happen okay it is brutal and uh uh
someone flagged it because they posted a
screenshot saying the video is fake and
from some other time or some other place
it was a false flag it was a false
likely someone made a fake screenshot
and uh it's really easy to do you can
you can pull up the video on a search
engine and then you can inspect and edit
the the uh uh the script to make
whatever dates you want to say and then
screen grab it's that easy or you just
go and paintbrush and just change it so
apparently wre did the groundwork and
found like no Donald Trump Jr is not
posting fake stuff he's posting real
stuff and it's funny like when w is
defending Trump Jr I mean wow there's
Unity here in this country I guess but I
want to bring up another another uh
tweet here this is something I tweeted
and uh let me see if I can get a bigger
image of this the first image is a tweet
from Andy no where it's a Palestinian uh
Palestine celebration rally in deborn
Michigan where the speaker says when you
go to a black lives matter rally you see
Palestinian Flags when you go to a white
supremacy rally you see Israeli flags
and then a tweet from the ADL white
supremacist leaders are openly
celebrating hamas's attack on Israel
cheering okay you get the point this is
like so much is being exposed here the
lies of the machine are falling apart
the the the the culture war is just
imploding right now and we are being
proven right this right here is one of
the the best pro Palestine groups claim
white supremacists love Israel and the
ADL claims white supremacists are
mocking Israel for being attacked yeah
are both true I mean this is nuts yeah
according to the videos I saw according
to ADL white supremacy has a perfect ESG
score
right just covering all their bases yeah
exactly and now there are a lot of
people who are outraged that the ADL and
the splc have not condemned black lives
matter as hate groups for supporting
terrorism in Israel and and Jonathan
greenblat who is uh the head of the ADL
went on MSNBC criticizing them of their
coverage of this saying because they
were calling it like you know militants
and he's like these are terrorists who's
writing these scripts like bro you
defended these people relentlessly over
the past years and we kept begging you
stop man they're lying and now you get
an overt Act of Terror undeniable like
look I'm seeing Libertarians who are
like no war no intervention being like
yo that was messed up what they did like
wow like this is brutal and now the ADL
nowhere to be found when BLM I'm sorry
dude the ADL is being insulted and
attacked by black lives matter who are
supporting Palestine Hamas terrorists
and they can't even come out and call
them a hate group or or condemn it I
think it just shows exactly what what
these groups represent yeah ADL spent
the last year telling last many years
saying the worst example of
anti-Semitism is anytime you bring up
George Soros there you have it and then
now look at this we have all of it on
video and just totally silent uh I would
like to see the ADL and the splc publish
their article saying black lives matter
as a hate an anti-semetic group you know
what's funny is we've known this since
the woman's March yeah when when tablet
magazine published like they're pushing
insane anti-semitic conspiracy theories
and there it is there it is everybody
you know you know here's the
problem this was uh man when was this
this was like six years ago the ACLU
defended unite the right in
Charlottesville saying you have a right
to free speech and then they started
losing a bunch of donors and then all of
a sudden their message changed Money
Talks yeah it's like like I mentioned
these har Harvard kids who are like no
we didn't mean to sign that letter in
support of Hamas whoops I mean thec in
particular pedals in fear right they're
able to say you know you be nice to us
or follow our talking points or we will
put you on one of our lists and no one
will want to hire you because we'll try
to make it so whenever you show up
you're basically a Google felon I mean
this is how the SPC keeps its its donors
in check and it keeps its enemies at Bay
because it says we are the authority on
the on morality and if we decide that we
don't like you it's all over and the
thing is they are corrupt they don't
have any sort of moral standing to make
that judgment they're just the
institutional power that's there and
when they are needed most where are they
nowhere right theoretically this is the
time that they should be the most
outspoken and instead they're going to
wait until one of their biggest donors
says what they what they want them to
say and then they're going to follow
suit well we need to Lobby uh uh the ADL
and the splc to to put black lives
matter as a anti-semitic hate group on
all of their Pages if they were really
serious about anti-Semitism you think
they'd do it right away but they would I
don't I I'm questioning their they do I
mean they kind of would have to right it
would be pretty I didn't even take the
check after before to no they're not
working right now they're not updating
anything that's why there's that's why
there's they're looking for what Nick
ventes is saying right now they're
trying to change the subject so quickly
or again like I said they are waiting
for their biggest donor to tell them
what they're comfortable with and then
they'll abide by that messaging yeah I
obviously have some some hard feelings
about these organizations but I think
they're just not trustworthy and instead
they they present themselves in ways to
ruin other people's lives and to take
money from people who really think that
potentially they are doing good that was
that's the hardest thing about all
liberal causes to me there are
potentially people who are you know
compassionate who really believe these
organizations are saying what they what
they pretend they are doing and uh it's
just not the case they're being swindled
exactly I don't know if you ever
experienced this while you were uh doing
your circuits on Fox uh I mean you were
on Tucker show pretty regularly for a
while yeah yeah lots of Fox shows not
just Tuckers yeah but experience what
experien the that you can see there are
people who believe something on the left
really TR really dearly but ultimately
they're being misled oh absolutely yeah
and you can't can't I mean you can't be
angry at all of them you know I've got
like Democrats in my family that you
know they sincerely believe it you can't
really they don't have any they're not
bad people no but yeah these these
organiz it's not just I mean it's every
organization you can think of it's like
the Human Rights Campaign and glad for
the gay stuff it's you know it's all TR
stuff um but yeah you're completely
right I splc and and ADL are pure evil
they they they're smear factories that's
all they do yeah and collect money for
it you know Semite is uh it really just
means like a a desert person like
someone from Asia and uh East Africa and
it includes Arabs Arabs are semites
acadians canites Hebrews Ethiopians um
so like if you hate Arabs you're also
anti-semitic yeah but
that's that's not what the ADLs Twisted
it to me that's not the no come on bro
people people use words to convey
meaning all right you can't they also
change definitions to control narrative
and if we use a if we all understand
what the word means as of today then we
can understand what they're trying to
say when they say it like when when
we've talked about this when the left
comes out and says racism I have no
problem saying they don't mean racism
the same way you do right right we will
translate their version of class and or
race-based oppression with privileged
groups and majority groups versus
minority groups whereas the right says
Prejudice based on race so thenation the
definition of anti-semitism that you
that you're saying that is is commonly
understood is that it's anti-jewish or
is it anti-israeli is it which one of
those anti-Semitism would the common
understanding would be anti-jewish right
yeah so secular anti- Hebrew no one no
one's saying it to to refer to
Palestinians it's not about religion
it's about where they're from it's
really about where you're from so but by
all means you can take issue with the
use of the word Semite in this way but
we know the idea being conveyed right I
do I do but you know that's so that's it
I don't the term to to make I don't who
I don't I don't know that anyone
hijacked it that sometimes terms become
the like Words happen like people use
words Xerox became a verb right this is
a common thing Kleenex yeah like now be
proper names become verbs because of
whatever reason and for whatever reason
for good or bad whatever your criticism
is this is the idea being ConEd I
suppose I bring it up only because we
are in an information war and it's
better to arm yourself with the
knowledge of past definition is that
really ever been a past definition yeah
and in 1770 it was created to describe
all those people from that area of the
world yes but anti-semite was that used
colloquially to describe the people of
that world or is it typically just
referred to Jewish people I don't know
let's find out yeah well well you you re
talking about the news spread the
narrative let us know you find out it's
you know I I can I can certainly
understand and respect that there are
people who definitely try to manipulate
words to gain power as we see with the
left changing the definition of sexism
and racism and all those things right
but if you're going to be talking to the
average person we simply try to just
understand the ideas that are being
conveyed and then you know push back you
have to go with a colloquial meaning
that makes sense yeah yeah and you can
criticize like I I have no problem
saying like you should use you know the
word Semite refers to many more people
than just Jewish people so by all means
you know you can be more specific and
just say they hate Jews like that's
actually probably more direct yeah and
you know I think anti-s kind of softens
the general idea just say they hate Jews
I was listening to One I think it was a
guy from Hamas talking and they were
saying that they wanted to eradicate uh
not not the Jews but um zionists which
is the idea of creating an Israeli it's
a political State it's not the it had
nothing to do with the religion itself
and and it was uh Wicked Christians so
like people that claim to be Christian
but don't believe in God or don't follow
the tenants of the faith like those
aren't real Christians anyway you guys
see what Lindsey Graham said we're in a
religious War yeah do whatever you have
to do level it level level that place or
whatever thanks lsy Graham but I bring
this up in response to what you're
saying because you know everything I
hear is you know it was it's the
Palestinian people who' have been
removed from their homes and it's like
wasn't it like someone else's before
that and someone else is before that and
someone else is before that what what
what did one of our members say bring
back Rome yeah this is the real that's
why you guys think Roman Empire it was
Ottoman for a long time and then before
that it was Byzantine which was like the
Eastern Roman Empire before that it was
the Roman Empire I think Greek for a
long time before that different
Alexander conquered from the Persians I
believe I'm not sure exactly so yeah
we're not in a holy war Lindsey Graham
uh we're not in any War uh firstly yeah
we are what a slip on his part yeah
exactly I mean I get like okay so I I'm
the first to admit and acknowledge like
I'm totally an emotional child and being
like Nukem you know but I realize that
that's my emotions and I can't really be
like tweeting and saying that this man
actually you know controls War bucks and
member of Congress I with Nikki Haley
she's saying the same stuff he is right
South Carolina like just today right now
I'm having a little bit of struggle
talking about it because it's like if we
were just hanging out the kitchen table
and just I would be like dark dark dark
thoughts because it's war and we're
talking about the horror and but we're
on TV any little idea I have right now
is like could spark conflict and so I'm
like I almost am like self-censoring for
better or worse but I think we're all
feeling I I think rational people are
feeling that not people go on who are
Senators on Fox News saying we're in a
holy war yeah I think it's good to be
cautious when you're talking generally I
mean I can understand working out ideas
with friends or people that you trust
but in this case having people like
Nikki Haley or Lindy Graham say you know
we are in a holy war or you know
advocating for more interal Theory you
have to remember that they are sending
your family members to War I mean Nikki
Haley does have a a husband who's
deployed to Africa right now I believe
but for the most part they aren't
talking about things that affect them
they're talking about things that affect
more workingclass mainstream Americans
they're willing to make them make the
sacrifice and I don't know if that's
actually something we should do right I
mean ultimately I know I make this point
when I'm on all the time but the
American government is supposed to serve
the American people and so even if the
the two countries are having a religious
conflict I don't know that it mean it's
our duty to intervene on their behalf
right like what is Our obligation to our
people first and and I don't know that
it's sending young men and women to a
war that we are not necessarily invited
to be a part of even though some some
sides may want us to intervene you're a
7-year-old confirmed Southern Bachelor
like Lindsey Graham he doesn't have to
worry about his children being affected
by this yeah I mean he doesn't that's
it's completely right and I think I mean
him of all people yeah and again like
it's it's it's hard to be online right
now I don't know if you feel this way
again but like it makes me more and more
cynical right people who call for us to
intervene or war no one calls for
something that they don't gain from so
what does Lindy Graham gain from this
what does Nikki Hil gain from this what
does Joe Biden gain from this because
the American people lose from us getting
more involved in this conflict that's
true that's well I hope you guys are
ready for this from American Military
news report Hamas calls for Global Jihad
invasion of Israel and attacks on Jews
worldwide on October 13th American
Military news is News Guard certified
100 out of 100 if that means anything to
you and they say a leading and founding
member of Hamas khed Michal reportedly
called for a global Jihad on Tuesday
asking Muslims around the world to
Target people of Israel on Friday
October 13th video of Michelle's
reported cult to violence was posted on
YouTube and remains up on the platform
as of Wednesday at 10: a.m. according to
a translation an analysis of the video
by author brother Rashid Marshall
referred to his proposed day of anger as
the Friday of the AL AXA flood which
will send a message of Rage to the
zionists and to
America okay so you know I'm kind of
worried well that's they showed their
numbers they showed their numbers this
week how many are in this country yeah I
was say should we talk about our street
sweep border policy yeah how many how
many we know how much how many Hamas
individuals are in the United States no
no I was saying with the rallies with
the people who are the na no we saw you
know that there are plenty of people out
there that are happy to commit vence uh
so I live in New York City so that's
obviously a prime target if people want
to do this so under our last mayor and I
doubt that the current one mayor night
life has changed this uh and I talked to
Cops about this actually from my last
book the entire and n ypd anti-terrorism
unit was directed to only focus on white
supremacy Lone Wolf white supremacist
terrorist under DeBlasio and I'm sure
it's probably still the same and uh even
cops I was talking at the time were like
yeah it doesn't exist like they're
mythical creatures there's no white
supremacist terrorist in New York City
this one cop I spoke to was saying know
they send the nyp terrorism unit to go
train with the FBI and even the FBI guys
were like yeah no it's Islam this was a
couple years ago like don't listen to
what they're teaching you but still they
took all resources away from Islam
even though since 911 there have been
something like a dozen either successful
authored terrorist attacks in New York
City M so is the NYPD prepared I mean
what I haven't heard I don't think so
mayor nightlife say anything about the
anti-terrorism unit and what they're
doing I don't I I I don't think it's
it's just going to be New York I mean
New York's a big Target but yeah this is
the concern look Kevin McCarthy and
Ronda Sanders both pointed this out you
know whether you like any of them or not
okay our our Southern border is so
extremely porous and we know that
several hundred every year and now more
it's it's gone substantially higher are
on the terror watch list I don't know if
if you want to trust this stuff or trust
our int agencies or any of this I'm just
saying like our border is open okay and
there are people coming through who are
not from South America there there are
people from China coming through no no
joke there are people from Africa coming
through and of course there are people
from the Middle East coming through so
if Hamas is trying to bring in sleeper
cells they've been they've been able to
do it for some time under the Biden
Administration when they then say we're
going to send a message to Israel and
the United States I have concerns about
what that may
and it's the one time I hope the uh uh
uh you know our law enforcement can do a
good job of something instead of just
framing you know rednecks for trying to
kidnap people I always hope they can do
a good job but they just don't always do
a good job I mean the the Border crisis
is something that has been an open issue
and we know that other countries are not
going to say oh well America seems to be
struggling to work this issue out so
we'll just let them we won't send
anybody we're not going to take
advantage of it uh we have no idea
what's what's in this what what the
issues we have rought for our country
are because we have left our border so
poor us for so long and the Biden
Administration did nothing to stop this
so should hopefully you know
everything's fine on Friday hopefully
nothing happens but if anything happens
we should look directly to the Biden
Administration oh did you see the the
Air Canada pilot that he got
fireden he was just posting what was he
posting signs in support of
Palestine Pro Palestine and like people
were saying like he was so radical in
his speech they were saying Jewish
people should feel scared to with him
and he was put on leave and I'll that's
the thing CU you can be Pro Palestine
and
pro-israel I want you can I want
coexistence among I know I understand
the violence has gotten to a point where
the vengeance is on people's minds but
that doesn't mean you can't support
their both of their rights and and
Define interventions to survive there
there there are uh uh Arab Arab Israelis
that live in Israel MH so I mean the
issue seems to be more so religious and
and uh I get the I was talking to Serge
about this before the shows he made a
claim that it was oh I I mentioned this
that it was about Zionism and he didn't
really mention Judaism and wicked
Christians not not Christians themselves
uh ones that purport to be Christian and
like people the Zionism is the idea of
creating an Israeli State a political
state in that area of the world has
nothing to do with the religion I mean
you could argue then that Israelis all
Jews are from Israel you know judah's
father was Jacob Israel so they're all
descended from Israel but that doesn't
mean that every Israeli is Jewish
because Israel had a lot of sons
so there's a lot of um Orthodox hidic
Jew I don't know if they're actually
hiic they they look hidic and I've seen
them protesting in New York before that
are really anti-israel like they're
super against the Israeli State yeah for
religious reasons I don't believe that
it's I can't get into the exact theology
but uh yeah there's a lot of sances I
mean you can be Pro Palestine You Can Be
pro-israel You Can Be pro-jewish You be
anti-jewish so there's a lot of things
that are going to this not just like as
simple as like that's that's what Ryan
Long's jok's about it's not just one
side of thing he say i' I've had all the
stances it's like there's not as it's
not as simple as that with this I'm Pro
Abraham yo and Abraham spoke to God that
dude was legit and he had an awesome
family his kids were badasses and they
spawned great tribes of people so if we
can stay focused on that guy I we have
something in common everybody wants
control over the Holy Land yeah that's
what it's been over thousands of years
read the uh forward.com wrote about the
red heer yeah and so apparently
beginning of September there there I'll
give you a really quick simple version
because I don't want to talk too much
about it but the general idea is that
this is a symbol of like the pro the
Messianic era returning or something
like that yeah and so it's just
Christians and and Jews tend to be
aligned in a lot of ways as to what they
expect to happen what they want to
happen and so that's why there's
coexistence whereas Islam is more so at
odds which is a large portion of the
conflict I was listening to the Quran
last night I've been doing like 30
minutes of it at night or something like
that and they were talking about uh
Ishmael who is son of Abraham and he's
descended from ishma come the tribe of
of Islam but he's like hanging out with
his dad and they're just talking and I
started to feel like I was there with
them it was wild man like you start to
feel like you're part of that tribe when
you listen to the stories and I I
imagine it's the same with his brother
with Isaac I haven't listened to a lot
of what Isaac did with his dad but like
I understand the pride of being related
to that and to to know and to be able to
track back your Dynasty to the people
cuz those dudes were like for whatever
reason I don't know if it was like the
strain of the environment that for that
made them listen to God like under great
tension you have no other choice you
start to hear it or like if you if
you're starving you know then there's
better chance you're going to hear it
because you're not clouded what should
regular people do right don't panic but
are people paying attention to this
stuff I'm worried about what what could
or may happen I think Israel is going to
be on high alert obviously and this
could this could be this this statement
this guy put out is escalation and
that's just bad yeah outright but if
there's already ongoing attacks there's
already rocket attacks if something
happens in the United States
man I don't want to see the US get
involved in another you know conflict
but it looks like that's where we're
going right with Special Special
Operations being offered up to Israel
and uh you've already got a bunch of
politicians calling for direct support
more funding more aid but and war with
Iran right Yep this is making me think
of Putin he made a statement and it's
there's a video of a Jackson Hingle
tweeted it out and he's basically saying
if men decide to fight Let Them Fight
leave the women in children alone he's
like in he's in a bad place right now
and I'm not the greatest Earth even
Putin standing with is you can't do this
he wanted some land let's like go easy
not that he he didn't make life good for
the ukrainians the last few years but
you could say that maybe other people
were involved in I think it's morale
crushing I think no matter no matter who
you are as a leader like let's there's
let's say there's the Red Faction and
the blue faction and they're at
War everyone as human beings have
similar desires and understandings and
despises seeing women and children
killed not every person but of of
civilized countries like obviously we're
at odds with Russia and China but you
will demoralize your Fighters if you're
actively saying go out there and kill
kids they're going to be like man I
don't want to fight anymore like it's
just you're not fighting for anything
you can you can recognize y yeah they
gota they got to trick themselves into
thinking that the enemy is like a rat is
like not not a human but even then
targeting children is going to be
extremely difficult it's kind of like a
Rat's Nest like you don't you don't
spare the baby rats you just take it out
right but my point is in a civilized
country in like a modern developed
Nation I should say not don't
necessarily mean civilized I don't know
but in like Russia for instance if if if
if he goes to if Putin goes to his
troops and says yes what happened in
Israel haha we're we're for it he's
going to demoralize his men yeah I don't
think Russia's the bad guy they've been
made out to be it's like the reason why
we have these like war crimes and these
laws is because we're kind of like dude
we might fight but you know leave the
kids out of it and then we we have that
hope that the other the other faction
May respect not killing the children but
then you know one of the things we've
learned consistently in the Middle East
is uh kids are not spared I was talking
to uh some dudes a while ago in the Army
who had been deployed and they said the
scary thing is imagine you're you're
you're in a convoy you're in a truck and
you're delivering supplies and then all
of a sudden a little kid walks out into
the middle of the road what do you do
got to shoot him in the middle military
and the kid has strapped a bomb to his
chest exactly and the kid could have a
bomb you don't what do you do I'm com
you don't know you don't know I don't
know don't have the answers it's like
that's the difficult thing you're
dealing with when you're when you're
over there is they will use children yep
yeah they did in Vietnam too I mean it's
probably an act of desperation you know
when the vietn the Vietnamese they were
living underground because the carpet
bombs were so intense so they would send
kids walking into camp with a basket I
don't think desperation so much as uh
determination to win at all costs I
think are willing to sacrifice for that
I mean that is something that they if if
you believe your cause is is the most
important thing you could ever achieve
in your life then what is the bar where
is the line why wouldn't you send
children to it because then they are
ultimately serving this great cause I
just got a little cassandre just uh hit
me up that the Biden White House has
walked back the Baby Comet really uh
this is tweeted out from yeah we're
going to have to look at Evan Hill at
Evan Hill clar from the White House
regarding Biden's remarks I've been
doing this a long time Biden said at the
White House I never thought I'd see
baby I never really thought I would see
oh man I see this is why I say you gotta
be skeptical don't trust Joe Biden
Washington Post has the story what yeah
that's amazing let me uh where where
what what is this it just jumped Let's
uh let's say uh
B uh no where's where's like he's got a
screenshot here clarification of the
White House recing B Marks uh a White
House spokesperson later clarified that
us officials in the present have not
seen pictures or confirmed such reports
independently the president bases
comments about the alleged atrocities on
the claims from netanyahu's spokesman
and media reports from Israel according
to the White House but he said he saw
them and that he confirmed that they
were real yes saw confirmed and then
when you click the link to the article
here here's said I never really thought
that I would see have
confirmed pictures of
terrorists beheading
children I never thought i' hey we all
knew Joe Biden was a scum but wait he
didn't say he did he just said I never
thought I would I never thought I would
see have
confirmed pictures of terrorists maybe
he's more clever than we
thought he read the script weasel words
assumptive language where you're right
he didn't say he saw it yeah he didn't
say he said he never thought he would
and he didn't so he's good but the
implication is of course that you did
see it saying I never thought I would
especially with this big emotional pause
like he's so overom by motion can't
finish his sentence yeah when I go to
the Washington Post link I just get in a
dead link it's not taking me to the
story did they delete the story no I
think they're updating it is updating
but I'm not seeing what he what he what
this guy screen grabed is not appearing
on Washington
Post washhington Post has now removed it
because the White House has to walk back
their walk back jeez what's real man
this could be a fake a fake debunking
right yeah who knows but he never said
that he saw it that that clip does not
appear in the article
so this screenshot from Evan Hill who is
a Washington Post Visual and forensic
investigations at wo whatever this link
is is not what he
posted so I don't know where where this
is coming
from so I don't know man no idea yeah
well let's stay stand on Biden's words
he never thought he would see it and
that's all he said so as far as I know
he never saw it he never claimed to have
seen it he never thought he would
confirm that I have no information he
never said that he did confirm it it's
not not good though that the leader of
our country is being so ambiguous in his
speech in a way that could potentially
be seen as inflammatory and calling for
more intervention on the US like it's
not okay that it's not clear this is a
time when we need Clarity he is supposed
to offer this to the American people and
he's not yeah he just wants to be on on
the right side of History you know so
like Ryan long he doesn't really know
what statement he's supposed to put up
yet he's waiting to hear all I can say
is right now this tweet from the Evan H
from Evan Hill The Washington Post I'm
not seing corroborated anywhere else in
fact all of the most recent stories from
the past few minutes just show Biden's
quotes of him saying implying that he
had seen it so that Washington Post link
is dead so I don't know what he's
posting H so I I I assume it is this is
what I saying I'm skeptical I'm not
about to start trusting Joe Biden right
there you go wow did they run it as if
he said that he saw they ran the article
that we read earlier with the oh dude
look at this NBC uh was it NBC News
Biden say he saw he phot he said that he
could he couldn't he didn't think he
ever would that's all he said I never
really thought that I would see and have
confirmed pictures of Terrace beheading
children all right hey look if you want
to get line you would never say unless
you didn't want people to think that you
did see it I think
I not I think to verify what he said
you'd need the the two minutes leading
up to the statement I I never thought I
would see a video of Joe Biden
mercilessly beating a child I never
thought I would confirm it either yeah I
never thought I would to confirm it yeah
yeah you can't sue me Joe I never said I
saw a video of it you said you never
thought you see exactly yeah oh jeez oh
my god wow this is the beginning man
this is like this is the future of
warfare is your mind future man if they
can get you to turn on your to turn on
your neighbors like that's how that's
the best way to win is to get your curve
infow Wars info wars you definitely man
it's weird these are wild times man it's
totally crazy these are wild times my my
friends do you you want to know how Wild
these times are it's this wild Jen yuger
has formally announced he is running for
president wonderful and so we went over
this before uh Phil leonti tweeted at
him said I thought you were born in
Turkey apparently his parents were US
citizens wow no way so he was born in
tur that that's that's what people are
saying he was born in tur his way into
this his parents were Turkish but were
also American citizens that means that
he was born of American citizen parents
and that would like right Ted Cruz he
says yes I'm running Joe Biden for the
Democratic nomination Joe Biden is down
24 points on the economy he has no
ability to make up that kind of ground
on the most important issue we need a
new candidate now
oh party no I just got to say is that
going to run of the DSA what what is
this bro hold on no no no no I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm like kind of upset about
this this website is poorly done it is
no for real like come on man this makes
me think he's absolutely not serious at
all about this and it's like here's a
chance to get a big platform and and
right this this does not look like a
legit legitimate we I don't know maybe
I'm just being a dick I mean it looks
like it's from like 1998 so it looks
like he whipped it together like 3 days
ago like he just started think thinking
about but he talked about this what
several weeks ago oh yeah he did yeah
like a month or two ago sure think it
for years I'm I'm sure most the most
important election of our lifetimes we
need a new candidate he says Biden is 13
points lower than when he barely beat
Trump in the Electoral College 44,000
votes Biden is 24 behind points behind
Trump on the economy the most important
issue Biden is currently trailing Trump
when he has to win the popular vote by
five points to win the electoral college
wow he says time offer mothers Paid
Family Leave higher wages $50 minimum
wage affordable health insurance public
option fight corruption and
gerrymandering uh the end gerrymandering
thing is like extremely naive I think
that's like yeah because like we've
talked bit about quite a bit these
people will be like have you ever looked
at Congressional map and you notice
there's like a block here and there's
like a little Thin Line and then a block
There Yet the reason for that sometimes
or I say the general reason for it is
you don't need a congressional district
on dead Farmland like that's one guy who
lives there you don't need a
congressional district on like a big
plot of government property either y the
congressional districts are where people
are right and so that means
congressional districts are going to be
shaped very oddly that being said fair
point it is typical among political
parties to try and figure out how to win
as many congressional seats through
Jerry mandering so that I understand but
a lot of the arguments they make for it
we don't want to end Jerry mandering in
in in we don't want to end this we want
maps to be drawn out but we probably
want a more fair method a more
appropriate method but I think the the
actual reality is there is no legitimate
way to do it any differently right
that's just it there's there's no way to
be like it should just guarantee for
Democrats or Republicans but anyway
outside of that you could pick like a
Rand for you could do a random subsect
of people within an area and be like if
you get if you draw one then you're
going to be part of
this caucus this time if you're draw to
then you're part of this caucus so your
vote goes towards the the the related
caucus so it doesn't matter where you
live your vote doesn't go to your
locality it goes to a random because
we're kind of decentralizing where it's
not about like it's all not local
anymore it's you know a polling place
right like that would be very difficult
for polling places to to pull off I
think because I just feel like that's
such a precarious uh bureaucratic system
already can we add to the uh polling
Aggregates now that he's an officially
declared for sure he's a far superior
candidate to to see a Jen Biden debate
because I feel like that could be really
entertaining Jen would run circles
around Joe Biden I think a lot of people
would run circles around Jo Biden to
that's I want to see an Ian cross and
Joe Biden debate like Joe Biden would be
confused the whole time and just like
I'd love to I'd listen to him till his
brain starts to work again and he starts
to be like what do you mean he's going
to sun sun down he'd be like 20 years
younger that's my goal with Joe Biden
get him to snap out of it and remember
who he is I want to see a Joe Biden V
debate so bad cuz you imagine the the
racist things that Joe Biden would oh so
true oh it would be so funny like he's
easy to humiliate but I'm concerned that
he's our commander so I want him to be
strong until he's no longer the
commander then I don't care what he does
homie is 80 years old dude he's not
going to snap out of it he's going to
degrade called
neurogenesis certainly possible neur
okay here's what you do you pump him
full of NAD and stem cellsin yeah and
sure that about PP full of but full of
what about Jen joining the Gavin Nome
disantis debate on November 30th oh that
be I'm for it I'm I'm totally for it I I
want Jen on the debate stage I think I
think Jen would do better in the debates
than Nome and disantis probably knows
ISS no question I mean Jen Huger is a is
a media personality he said a bunch
right he talks for a living I think it
would be absolutely fantastic I I I'm
willing to bet he would say a lot of
things he'd actually agree with too yeah
I think Jen yuger would be a better
candidate than anything the Democrats
have to offer right now but I would I I
don't want Jen to win but that's why
I've said before it's like I'd rather
I'd probably rather have him than any of
the other Democrats at the very least I
think he could be pressured into a
pardoning Assange you know it's going to
be bad true I think his policies are bad
but I'm more inclined to believe we're
going to we would get less war with Jen
than with any other Democrat Nome is
going to be like you know just like B
tier Hillary Clinton there more Neo neol
establishment garbage yeah this is great
news that he's running I'm I'm glad that
he's running I want more
anti-establishment I want more you know
different Uhl political backgrounds to
be challenging the machine yeah we could
get him in here yeah chunk yogurt 24 who
should uh should we bring him in here
with somebody to debate we invited we
have invited this guy to come on the
show like 87 times 88 what it's all
about magic number on the campaign Trail
so he really wants to be here we've
hosted multiple presidential candidates
I'm just going to say it I would I would
love to have him on the culture War show
with uh Phil or maybe someone else come
on to have like a calm conversation
about these issues I mean yeah maybe if
it was like Yi Phil and him specifically
just culture War discussing policy and
and and stuff whereas you know like IRL
is like we have a bunch of news articles
that we go through this is the big news
Jen just announced he's running that's
why we're talking about it culture war
is Friday mornings and it's usually much
more just like we're going to talk for
two hours about whatever we feel like
talking about wherever the conversation
goes yeah I'm down let's let's you know
say we can book him cool nice I I I I am
glad that he's running I think he's
better than all the Democrats I do and I
and I I like if I had a choice between
him or Trump I'm voting for Trump no
question but I mean to be completely
honest if I had choice between
like like if this is tough Joe Biden or
Mitt Romney I'm out I gotta go with r i
don't know what Romney's up to but
Biden's so low right now I'm just I'm
just out Romney's retiring he said I'm I
need to leave because I'm too old
but how about this that's admirable Joe
Biden or Nikki Haley Nikki Haley I can't
take the old man he's not there nii
Haley I know no no way nuh not abing
Nikki Haley is like she's like I don't
want to go to war with Iran RFK at that
point you know right right we have the
nice he's there for a reason but I don't
even like RFK I don't so my the reason I
bring this up is where is Jen on the top
10 list of who you would consider voting
for I would say this three he's up there
for me yeah he's certainly not on the I
never would
because he has an a light
anti-establishment vent but he is still
fairly establishment but I I I can
respect that he argued with h about uh
letting criminals out of prisons and I
think I I would look if if if I'm
looking at Nikki Haley and Joe Biden and
the only other candidate was like I'll
pardon Julian Assange I'd vote for I'd
vote for J yeah like that that that
issue matters a lot to me I think that
was an outright egregious evil committed
by the United States I think Donald
Trump wanted to bring Julian Assange
back back to the US because Julian had
information that would benefit Donald
Trump and and strike it the heart of the
deep State I can respect Trump wanting
that information but ordering the ex
tradition of of Julian Assange is just
using a man's life for political
purposes so but you know I that's that
that's about all I can say I think
that's how it would break down for a lot
of people they would then look at what
are my top two issues and who is most
closely aligned on those even if
everywhere else I don't agree with them
I mean if you have two candidates you
really don't like you pick the one that
has at least a chance of giving
something you want well maybe he'll run
as an independent and then really Spike
the Democratic party gosh be so funny we
have multiple Independents in the race
but here y'all need to understand this I
support Jen huger's efforts here 1
million per for another reason as well
he doesn't need to run as an independent
despike
Democrats by running he is pulling
donations away from other Democratic
candidates that's it Y and donations
matter contributions matter spend
matters and so if Joe Biden was running
as the incumbent unopposed which he
should have been in any normal cycle but
because the dude's brain don't work he's
got competition all those donations are
in his pocket it's one of the reasons
incumbents tend to win that all the
money flows to them they don't have to
beat off a primary for lack of better
term and uh right now what Jen is doing
is basically saying donate to me and
progressives will they will and then not
every single one but a lot of them and
that's money that Joe Biden could use
that he won't be having it sort of feels
like me and chank yuger and Matt Gates
were really good friends that used to
hang out a Taco Bell and talk politics
like that's how I see those guys like
tempers flare but I don't care it was
more about the ideas I love it I love
that they're so intense and in their own
lane and they're doing their own and
they're willing to run for president
like this was the most compelling thing
that RFK Jr said during his announcement
that he's going to be independent which
is that it it should be about serving
the people and it should not be about
I'm going to he said there there there
has to be a moment where you realize
you're not going to get your way on
everything uh and it's not that I think
he is the perfect candidate but I think
this idea that we have to give up the
addiction to fighting for the one side
we've stuck ourselves on it is worth
hearing right I mean and we are seeing
it bear itself out right now as as the
news plays out I cut you off I'm sorry
no no no no
that I was going to say no did you were
you always conservative or you where did
you develop politically oh I was I was
one of those 2016 babies that was like
always voted left and and um and what
changed uh I was centor I started doing
a bunch of stories that year that were
very because I I wasn't really I mean I
was writing for like the New York Times
I was writing for all these liberal
places but I wasn't super political and
um that summer pulse happened I was
reporting on that that affected me a lot
Islamic terrorist attack then I profiled
Milo yannopoulos for a magazine which is
the first time I met him and then you
know you're saying all these things I
was like I've never heard anyone say
that before that's exactly what I think
but it was just sort of I mean it is a
basic thing of just looking like for the
you know suddenly looking into
everything that I thought you know I was
one of those like I of course I believe
in equality I'm a Democrat you know I
work in the Arts um but then I started
looking into everything I'm like why who
whoa they're lying about this and if
they're lying about that why are they
lying why do they have to lie if they're
so right and then I I never really I
think a lot of and I think a lot of
young people are like this too on the
left is they don't really think of the
endgame of what they're advocating for
I'd never just really given it much
thought it was just the platitudes mhm
and in your Social Circle it sounds oh
yeah absolutely and then of course when
I came out as you know not left I don't
really say conservative anymore I think
I said conservative like a minute but I
don't really know what that means so
yeah so yeah you know what I mean like
um oh yeah I was like fired from my jobs
and all that stuff um but um yeah that's
uh that was mine I want to I want to
pull up this tweet Ben Shapiro is
getting into it with Tucker Carlson
Shapiro responds Tucker Carlson's moral
equivalency struggle session here and
I'll play a little bit uh from Ben for
you guys and Tucker by the way then
continued along these lines he didn't
interview with v ramaswami and he
likened what just happened in Israel the
the kidnapping of women and their rape I
mean he's showing video of this
happening like as he's talking about
this he compared that to drug overdose
deaths in the United States now I I
believe we should fully care about the
100,000 drug overdose deaths that
happened in the United States these are
two completely different issues to to go
this far a field to link the issues
you're the only reason you're doing this
is because you wish to downplay the
atrocity that just happened in Israel
you're not up playing the atrocity of
what's happening on America streets are
two different types of atrocities people
who are addicted to fentanyl sticking
needles in their arms and overdosing is
a is a is a moral blight it is a moral
atrocity and a moral evil for people to
kidnap women rape them and drag them
back to the Gaza border those are not
the same thing so uh oh man this is
interesting saying that Tucker is trying
to downplay the atrocities of what
happened that's a bold statement from
Tucker let me play a little bit here
from um I from Ben sorry let me play a
little bit from Tucker here I I got to
say you you mentioned moral outrage and
and I thought the videos from Southern
Israel were morally outrageous and I I
was offended by them and saddened by
them anyone who saw them I think was um
but you don't have to look far in the
United States for moral outrages also on
video and there's not a city in this
country not just the big cities but
cities of 10,000 people I was in one
yesterday that doesn't have some
constellation of drug addicted young
people living outside we call them the
homeless they're drug addicts and
they're addicted to drugs that were
imported across an open border Allowed
by the bid Administration and they're
dying more than 100,000 a year now you
could call it genocide you can call
whatever you want but it's the death of
over a 100,000 Americans a year and the
living death of millions more who are
living outside so this is interesting
because Tucker's talking about 100,000
young people dying from these failed
policies Ben's making it seem like he's
just comparing drug overdoses in general
to what we just saw happen in Israel I'm
curious you guys think whose team are
you on on team Tucker or team Shapiro
well obviously here's Ben Shapiro
putting a muzzle in someone's back
because he's not crying hard enough
about you know Ben's number one issue I
I assume it's like what is Tu Tucker's
being very consistent he's extremely
nationalistic populist and he's making a
point of yes we're all horrified by
these images but you know I'm focused on
my country I mean this it's very true to
who he is I mean he's not saying this is
outrageous or anything why Ben's upset
that Tucker's not angry enough I think
we're all pretty angry about it I mean
that's why he had 30 minutes of his show
dedicated to it with v and he want to
say let's not forget what's happening in
our own country where's the outrage here
I wish we were all as outraged about
what's happening in our country as we
are about what's happening in Israel
right now seems to be what he was
getting at but that's not good enough
for Ben Shapiro apparently or Ukraine
when we were all putting up the flags in
Ukraine I wish that we cared as much
about what was happening to the people
in Appalachia when they were being given
uh opioids at in mass and then being
made fun of in private emails I mean I
am not saying these things are even
comparable I think both parties are
maybe making a weird comparison but
there is definitely tragedy in America
and it is good to acknowledge that we
don't get we don't whip ourselves into
the frenzy that we have 100,000 dead
over this stuff a year yeah I mean
that's that's it's it you know like I
said Ben is saying one a person oding on
on heroin is is is a moral blight but
it's an atrocity to kidnap rape women
and drag them to the Gaza border okay
well Tucker's had 100,000 dead so you
know we we can talk about like I
absolutely agree
in in in the sense of what Ben is saying
that yes beating raping women and
kidnapping them and dragging the g a
border is is a moral atrocity well
beyond someone overdosing but Tucker
saying a 100,000 people overdosing I
think gets to the point of something
very serious here yeah poisoning an
entire Society poisoning entire Society
right yeah a different kind of attack
here here's the other thing I'll add to
this too it's
like there's a video uh uh I don't I
don't know if there was a video there's
a story out a Philly where a woman was
raped on a train in front of a bunch of
people I think they filmed it oh yeah
uhhuh yeah so women are being beaten
raped and kidnapped all the time in the
United States because of the crime and
because of the policies of these soft
these soft on crime Democrats these
policies are resulting in criminals
being released and then we just had that
woman in Baltimore who was presumably
raped and uh murdered on her roof this
Tech CEO now you've got the the guy in
in uh you've got the guy in New York
Ryan Carson I think his name was who was
stabbed and killed so you know look I
can understand organized actions by
Hamas into civilian areas is an atrocity
but I I think Tucker is making a a
relevant point he maybe could have
articulated a little bit better if you
wanted but he mentioned 100,000 deaths
that's what you would call derailing uh
what Tucker did he derailed the
conversation into another uh direction
that he wanted segue he took them into a
tangent yes a tangential segue so
we but does Ben not watch Tucker Carlson
it would become so out of character if
Tucker Carlson came on and started like
we need to go to war and this is the
worst thing that's ever happened in the
history of mankind if it were about
another country you know this is this is
the other thing this this is Tucker
Carlson doing a segue in a conversation
you'll say yes I do understand that you
like the color blue something else
that's blue is the sky have you noticed
that in the sky we do it all the time on
this show I do it particularly I do free
association where if you're talking
about a color I might mention something
else that the same color you're like
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about this that's
derailing Segways are different you're
derailing me right now anyway joking
Segways are when we we will talk for 15
or 20 minutes and then we'll say we'll
be talking about fake news and I'll say
speaking of fake news we have this
article we segue on by saying it's as if
they caught the end of his segment on on
the attack and then they the beginning
of his segment on the drug overdoses and
he's trying to shift the conversation
from Israel into American issues by
saying you know these things are really
really bad we have some things that
we're really concerned about here in the
United States too normal segue because
he has a presidential candidate on right
and he spent the last 20 minutes talking
I look man I like Ben and I respect his
anger frustration um he's probably
really scared he probably has a lot of
friends over there I mean absolutely his
family and friends Terri happening he
was there I don't remember I could have
misread a tweet online oh I don't know
going put up this thing being like Ben
is safe he's just observing the the
holiday so he's not on on social well
good I could be totally off on this
nobody I I I completely respect Ben's em
like emotional state he's he's highly
he's he's highly agitated I don't mean
that to be mean I mean he's clearly this
is affecting his family probably his
friends definitely uh there there are
I'm sure that you know he may know
people who are who are victimized
injured maybe even killed but I just
want to say on top of all that cooler
heads prevail and now isn't the time to
be like criticizing Tucker Carlson for
doing a segue and maybe you know if Ben
had approached it more calmly being like
Tucker you could do a better job please
let's I think it would have hit would
have landed better but again I can
understand why Ben's upset I'm not
trying to be a dick yeah apparently he
left just before it happened just so you
know yeah wow just before and and he
wasn't on the internet either because
they were observing Sabbath so ex do you
think it would be a good time to bring
like Israeli Scholars and uh or or I
guess to say Jewish Scholars and Muslim
Scholars together for a conference they
do that all the time is it good to do
right now or is it I mean we had Max
talking about it and it's just like it's
it's it's never enough yeah it's it's
just maybe if we do it we could
publicize it to another it's like a new
crowd culture War episode we get an Imam
and a rabbi a priest could that would be
epic it be super interesting the thing
is though like those are good and it's
good when people who are um expert in
their field they're they're studying the
religion whatever it's good for them to
talk about things but you have to
remember the people on the ground are
making decisions to participate in in
either side of or not and so someone
having sort of like an elite group of
Scholars having a conversation doesn't
mean that it's going to affect the
hearts and minds of the people that are
actually living in the realities of both
of these now honest I'm most concerned
about the kids that are nine they're
going to be 22 in 11 12 13 years and
remember this like the kids in 2009 that
whose sisters were blown up they're all
in their mid early 20s and they're ready
to fight I'm talking about like the the
Palestinians that were there during the
Israeli attack in 2009 or whatever you
want to call it so it it for in those
situations maybe if we're if we have
conversations early now in these 11 12
year olds that have lost their family
members have something to listen to then
maybe that'll help them clear you know
think properly over the next couple
decades while
you know that's like the best I can do
is is just talking on a microphone other
than going to Gaza which I want to do
too yeah I I think that it's not wrong
to want to have conversation they just
mean that the it's easy for us to who
who don't live in the middle of these
countries to say well if we just talk
about it more then maybe we'll be able
to reach an agreement and I don't live
with the cultural and religious um
complicated feelings that come with both
of these places I I live in America and
I'm Christian so some of the things that
go on are things that would be very
difficult for me to understand I don't
know that we are in a position to offer
a solution because and you know like all
conflict and war in history it's so
deeply complicated and it's uh not just
like one thing happened and suddenly
they're fighting this is a very layered
complicated um T contentious
relationship that has hit a very serious
breaking point and resulted in very
serious violence yeah it's like it's
been a thousand years you know it's not
it's not like it's is going to go away
tomorrow that's one thing that we can sh
for sure it's not going to just end
because some people discuss some things
and someone viewed them as being because
even within Islam they have different
opinions as to who leads like the
spiritual successor of Muhammad on Earth
so it's it's not going to be that easy I
just I know what you're saying and I get
it it's Noble but outside of a culture
War episode I don't know I want to do a
new show maybe every Tuesday uh Rel one
to two to three hours where we we fly in
religious experts it could be anybody
but if you guys support that in the
audience give me a five in the chat
because uh I've been thinking about a
lot and I don't think wasting time makes
any sense anymore but I mean the entire
region only well some only functions
with strong men in power looks what
happened they took out Gaddafi I mean
there there are such things as cultures
that really only understand force and
power yeah it's true I mean Russia's a
culture that only understands force and
power they want a strong man I think
that's hard for us to understand you say
like yeah it's hard for us to understand
like well let's just talk about it yep
we have local cops we've got this local
protective bubble that we all live in so
it's doesn't really matter if your
president's an idiot sometimes right
yeah exactly but it's not true it does
matter on the geopolitical stage just
doesn't really matter as much
domestically whereas in Russia if you're
president or in Chile I don't know if
the do the Russians have local cops or
is it federales all across the
Federation I I don't remember exactly I
remember that I I'm pretty sure it's
Federation cops I think
so Federation cop I want to ask you a
question about Tucker really quickly
were you uh did you see a shift in his
style cuz you observed him pretty
closely from when he left Fox and now
that he's doing his own thing
well you know he's very he's still an
employee of Fox News so he's uh under
constraints about what he's able to do
but just the style of his interviews
style of his interviews uh I think that
his I think he's I mean it's a different
show now because it's long form I guess
it's more similar to that Tucker Carlson
Today's Show I think that he's probably
um I think probably the lack of
structure is probably affecting him a
little bit I think May or negatively uh
I think he's just probably getting used
to it because he's worked at like a
jobby job for yeah 100 years in cable
news you know I think that the kind of
freedom and lap structure is maybe is
this something you kind of go into in
his book Tucker's time in media yeah I
mean most of the book is um I mean it's
you know his birth well not even his
childhood his father's childhood well
before that up until the book ends two
weeks after he was taken off the air and
he's sort of still dazed by it and going
through it how' you meet uh I was a
regular on his show I I was first
actually when I came out conservative
which was in a piece in the New York
Post uh I came out conserva yeah when I
came out conservative that was a
headline I'm a gay New Yorker and I'm
coming out conservative that was and
that coming out might have been harder I
don't actually oh it was it was much
harder way harder than coming out 15 in
the middle of the country man um but
that was February 2017 and he had me on
the show because of that article which
went viral had no idea it would had you
been writing biographies before that uh
not I'd written um magazine profiles
tons of those uh but not this is my
first biography how long did it take to
write it this book was um a little over
a year were you like in constant contact
with Tucker as you were writing it like
yeah I was yeah he was I try not to
bother I bothered him as little as
possible try to respect his time but I
spent tons of time with him in his home
and stayed his home by his assistance
and so would you go interview him take a
bunch of notes then leave go write as
much as you could and then come back and
hit him up again kind of thing uh I
tried to get it done in like chunks so I
would come hang out for a few days at a
time have my recorder going the whole
time and just kind of be there and then
get home transcribe it all go through it
because I'd already done you know I
there's a lot more you know when you're
writing about someone's career and all
that there's so much more you're already
working on to there's a lot of history
there there's a lot of work there tons
of that you know yeah did you find that
it changed you uh learning about someone
else and writing someone else's
biography it did yeah uh I think with
him particularly and and his wife Susie
it it made me not to sound corny but uh
it made me chill out a bit it made me
kind of remember what was important in
life what do you mean just because he's
such a he has a very um he's he he is
not negom Maniac he's not a jerk he's a
really sort of warm and interesting
person he has a very Balanced Life he's
he makes sure he can see the stars every
night you know things like that uh and
i't talking a lot about that he's very
into nature and uh and he has a really
lovely life and lovely family and so it
was sort of one of those like yeah I
need to remember what's important it's
not what's happening in the news he's
someone who very much knows that what's
happening in the news is not the most
important thing in the world him being
at the time as he was number one on Fox
you know when I was doing most This
research I find myself wondering about
that with America I mean all of Western
the world but definitely America's
workaholic culture you see people
especially women delay having children
or getting married because they think oh
my career needs to come first I need to
get to a certain level and we know
ultimately you know you you can always
be more successful you can always be
working for something more whereas uh
I've quoted this a couple times one of
the it was the guardian I think
published the story interviewing men who
hadn't had children and they just kept
saying Oh I thought it would happen so
you have these two forces saying I had
my I didn't put my eye on this thing
that ultimately makes life sort of have
a meaning that you can't just get from
dollars and cents or promotions at work
yeah that that that was something I I
discovered is that he's so he's so much
more interested in in the bigger
questions of morality Family Faith
Beauty than he is in politics per se
yeah you know which are far more
interesting conversations and the reason
we're supposed to have politics in the
first place to uphold our morality and I
think a part of his success was he's the
only person that could speak on those
things in mainstream media number one he
because he actually believed them and he
wrote all those monologues himself but
you know he could do a segment about
architecture like Sean handy can't do a
segment of architecture she doesn't care
about architecture you know and also as
you brought up starting Families how
young women get screwed by feminism and
and all these other lies that they've
been told and young men as well which we
don't talk about a lot no which he
certainly does yeah well I mean he's got
Sons right how can you not be conscious
of these things if you're watch you went
through them yourselves and you're
raising another generation of people who
are combating these narratives that
direct them to be ultimately unhappy and
servants to a a corporate machine that
chews them up and spits them out
absolutely yeah I mean and and yeah his
anti- corporatist stands in the most
corporate of settings on Fox News was
always quite amazing but it was also so
it's I mean so indicative of just these
Blurred Lines of what is left and right
anymore I mean the fact that the left
hates him so much and yet he and I think
one of the main reasons is that he just
so effectively holds a mirror up to what
they once were and what they still sort
of purport to be which would be like
free spe speech anti-war anti-
corporatist and now they are all of
those the opposite of all those things
and and it's the Tucker sort of Tucker
Carlson trumpy populist right I guess
that is very suspicious of those things
and calls them out now yeah that's and
that drives the left insane obviously
because they need to be like their AV on
guard fighting the man in of course but
they are the man but they are the man
they have been for a while I I thought
it was hard to argue that we're
countercultural when they are the they
are the culture right I mean I they
still don't see it
they do see it they can't admit it cuz
it's too painful right or they just
shatter right I always I always bring of
how the word boot licker just
disappeared as soon as they came into
Power boot licker there was term
disappeared I saw all my friends stop
saying it because it doesn't fit the
narrative for them you can't say that
anymore but as soon as I guarantee if if
Trump or another uh let's say like
Republican takes office or or
independent if RFK takes office that
word will come back mark my words so we
we it was in the article I just had
there was a drop down it was blocked but
post does say a White House spokesperson
clarified us officials in the president
have not seen pictures or confirmed
reports independently independently the
president based his comments about the
alleged atrocities and the claims of
netanyahu's spokesman and media reports
from Israel so uh who do you trust the
Washington Post or uh the president well
the president never said he saw them so
the Washington Post is just clarifying
that he saying someone else people who
are once again trying to backtrack
something the president said no no no no
we didn't hear anything from the spokes
people we saw this a statement from The
Washington Post The Washington Post say
the Washington Post is claiming yes okay
that someone said this yes someone told
them exclusively that this is H but they
can't name anyone and it says a White
House spokesperson later clarified that
us officials in the president had not
seen clarified to whom when how and
whose side is the post on are they in
the in the in the like the long video I
think they're if Joe Biden says I never
thought I would see it you're right he
didn't say he saw it if the washingon
post as a spokesperson clarified they
don't say where who to them to someone
else yeah The Washington Post could be
referencing a tweet they saw from a
White House spokesperson who claims to
have sent a message to someone about
something similar you don't we have no
idea it sounds like is someone in the
Israeli intelligence or somebody
contacted the Biden Administration and
told them that they had pictures and
they were confirmed then Biden as a boot
let's say Biden the lap dog has just
repeated it he didn't even say like I
was told that spokesman said it out loud
yes so then bid and media reports are
misal so bid echoing right just he's oh
my God welcome to F of War it's crazy
and and Biden is contributing to it
because either way this is him not being
clear in a statement and we can go with
he's got an agenda we can go with he has
Alzheimer's it's not a strong look for a
president and it's definitely going him
in the PO Tim Tim mentioned this earlier
but didn't elaborate but it was the
Saudi the the Iraqi thing in the 90s I
mean that's what made us sort of think
of this and what was he the whole story
was the the N Nira yeah yeah was it NAA
NAA yeah yeah claimed that saddam's
forces had pulling babies out of
incubators and left him to die right and
it turned out and it was used to testify
the first Gulf War yeah and it was
totally fake I support Israel Judaism
all of this but sending them into to
commit genocide against the Palestinians
will make them the world's most hated
country on Earth not by me but they I
people need to understand I know it's
like the breaking point has come it
feels like that
but I want to preserve the people the
PE I mean yeah it's a challenging
position we don't really know what to
say and I think again I I really credit
uh Ryan long for his his well Time video
here right like I think people want to
ultimately live with morality and have
compassion and want there to be a right
answer on the other hand it is very easy
for Americans to say like oh well I read
three articles from The Washington Post
so I know what's right and ultimately we
know that even our political leaders are
misleading or being misled there is no
Clarity on this issue you can't rush to
take statement you should condemn
violence you should you know pray for
people who are suffering but you can't
ultimately say I know exactly how to fix
this because we don't and what's wrong
with saying I'm I'm emotional right now
and and I don't have to have an answer
or I've got a solution potentially what
do you guys think about making offering
Palestine to become the 51st US
state no I don't why why would we do
that because I got I got an idea equally
as plausible as Ian's idea a pizza party
for everyone in Gaza and and in Israel
to come together and celebrate and then
we'll have the roll Stones play so I'll
tell you why because it would give
us do it it would give us a Trade Post
in the Middle East a permanent place to
go it give us a vacation spot like
Hawaii it give us
trade not right now but 30 4 years what
what you're saying is a joke okay um I
think I'd rather buy the B I'd rather
joke around and offer legitimate funny
weird Solutions than just watch people
die like what's the other I haven't
heard one solu other than that all right
here's an equally as plausible solution
to yours we we'll we'll have a whole
bunch of clowns I know you're going to
on it that's why I asked them man I
know you don't like it you already told
me that it's in it's psychotic so is
this war
dude another country we can't even get
Puerto Rico to be a 51st state what
you're saying is a non take over
greenand yeah whatever happened to that
we've barely developed Alaska this is
more of like saving their lives kind of
thing maybe not a state Maybe Colonial I
don't want to I don't want to we already
said we were backing Israel in this we
already said they're our allies so I I I
love how Ian's interventionism is so
extreme he wants to Annex and colonize
Palestine I want to do is into this
racist country I want to improve living
conditions in palestin because if you
support Israel you improve living
conditions in Palestine they'll stop
attacking they're they're attack no it's
not that's not it or there's a
likelihood that the attacks will
decrease if they're not starving to
death potentially potentially maybe but
no one can say you don't know and I
don't I don't think judging on these
actions that it I don't think from the
river to the sea has anything to do with
food no it does not what do you mean
from the river to the Sea exactly if you
don't know what that means maybe you
should put in context for people okay so
most people who are listening and
hearing you talk about making Palestine
the 51st state which you're probably
referring to the Gaza Strip have to
partition it with Israel but yeah right
okay
whiches when they when they chant from
from when they when they're chanting
from The River To The Sea they are
saying they will see
all of the land that is now Israel they
are not saying we're hungry help they're
saying from The River To The Sea I
understand the milit uh War goal of
Hamas but that's not the people I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
civilians how would you remove Hamas
from this we're going to Annex a country
that Hamas is in 44% support and then
we're going to have an occupied vacation
home in the Middle East that we are now
the US military would
occupy then we would have turned on
Israel and have a hostile relationship
like don't understand what they saying
the US military should occupy Palestine
and force them to our laws well this I'm
not saying to colonize or how else would
that look I want to offer them the
opportunity to petition to become a
state if they want because otherwise
they're going to get annihilated and
completely decimated and gen they're
gone so why is it why would you say that
the Americans should intervene on this
like why I just told you because we
could set up economic trade routes with
uh
israel2 million Palestinians can move
anywhere they want in the continental
United States and God knows how many in
that 44% support for
Hamas yeah Hamas would probably be their
governor they probably elect a so we
would give them all American ISL they
get Senators so like the squad gets two
more members there would be yeah that
would be part of the deal that would be
part of the deal I mean they would get
senators get representation they get
americ tax state yeah that actually my
friend that told me this he wanted to
make them both American St if we're
going to get another state I say we take
the Baja Peninsula next time we bail out
the Mexican Banks you know and then we
can increase our land that way at least
it'll be attach to us and it's way
easier to defend why would we take
doesn't make any sense the idea of
United States doesn't stop in North
America we could have a global citizenry
of United delocalized State Empire stuff
man this is like an
Empire what if the Sun never set starts
working out and now he wants total
Global intervention oh dude I don't care
what they're doing a North Dakota man
I'm not the kind of guy that would send
the you don't care what's happening in
our own country but you'd rather send
our military forces to two different
countries that doesn't make sense well
you know they defend themselves they
have state militia they have state
govern you you it would take 40 years
doesn't have a way to defend itself
they're clearly obviously able to launch
violent attacks Israel is obviously able
to retali don't conflate Palestine and
Hamas I'm not saying why not because the
Palestinians a lot of those people are
civilians they voted for it some of them
you said 44% yeah that's called the
plurality that's called some of them
that's less than half of them man and
that's voting and that's only
adults so so how many kids are in there
and they're not they're not h
m not right now let's how many 100,000
800,000 the thing is they're still
willing to put like a missile system
underneath on top of a school I know
they're like held host children's
hospital and stuff like that I know
they're being held hostage but like you
know even in under Geneva's rules like
if you're using a school or a hospital
whatever and you're using a missile site
there that's now a military site it's no
longer hospital that's why I'm proposing
radical Solutions because I understand
this military Doctrine dictates that you
wipe them out I understand yeah okay
well it's a nonsensical solution I I
know
politically physically militaristically
economically impossible to not
impossible but it would be ridiculously
hard but I mean understatement it is it
is for all intents and purposes
impossible you need there they would
acquiescence it wouldn't be a forc thing
so first you'd have to go to fulls scale
war with Iran uh because the moment you
bring any kind of uh us presence towards
Palestine for the purpose of offering
annexation Iran's going to declare
full-scale war Lebanon and Hezbollah are
already threatening to bomb the carrier
strike group that's there like it's just
nonsense come on
we'll go to super chats we're going to
go to super chats and hear what y'all
have to say so smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net good dud good job Noah
Sanders says I know you read read my
chat last night but the uncensored
episode from last Thursday still isn't
working on the website thanks for all
the work you do yeah who do we have me
and K are working on right now we have
to figure it out is it just something on
Rumble it might be we don't we haven't I
haven't actually checked with them we
have to do it it's noted right here on
the desk though guys so don't worry well
let's get that up B let's do it right
now can you message someone right now
and tell them to do it yeah I I'll be
able to look after the show all right
well I'll do it right now cuz we're not
going to wait till after the show so
we'll just uh I'll just get in this and
uh well doing that I'll take the
opportunity to shill my concept of
making Palestine the 51st state cuz it's
a good it's the best idea I've heard
it's not remember North Dakota Ian
doesn't care about you you know what
when I first heard the idea from a
friend I thought it was complete non I
was like yeah that's moronic and then I
shut the computer off and I was like
sitting there I think we should make
Switzerland the 51st state and then I
think we should also make Japan the 52nd
state like we can't just claim other
countries it doesn't make any sense
course we can we've been doing it since
the dawn of time yeah but people are
really
against let's violate the Geneva
conventions the hog conven let's go to
war with Iran Lebanon Saudi Arabia
Jordan uh let's let's military
industrial complex grows and grows
grow no Ian's right let's go to World
War III right now no more waiting send
in the strike groups instantly have war
declared on the United States and all of
its allies and nukes go flying over his
proposed idea of annexing Palestine for
the record World War III began in uh
September 11th 2001 and America's been
winning it you know what I'm tired of
waiting for the nukes to fly let's take
Ian's idea just get the nukes to launch
immediately I'm still against them being
a 51st state but it would be much FL
flashier this way Tim would you rather
be wrong be right would you rather be
wrong or be
dead what if you had to pick if you had
to pick one just in general but what
does that mean would you have to find
out that everything you thought was real
right was wrong or would you rather be
I'm wrong all the time honest question
wrong all the time that's why we bring
out a bunch of people different people
from different backgrounds and different
political opinions that's why when I
used to say things like you know I think
there was reasonable gun control I no
longer say these things that's why we
had a legitimate conversation numerous
times about abolishing the police and
why I've gone on to say that Michael
Mouse is correct that police absolutely
would kill children we saw this in Maui
he was right about that this is like
kind of the the premise of the show is
that we're learning and experiencing and
trying to understand the world but the
reality of annexing Palestine which
would fundamentally makes no sense
because are you talking about Gaza and
the West Bank together we'd have to
partition it so so you're talking about
first we have to militaristically force
a two-state solution which would then
result in war with Iran and Lebanon
probably Saudi Arabia if we forced it
yeah right so you we can't do that so
then there's there's that's it full stop
right now before you can offer up your
proposal you need a two-state solution
in Israel yeah okay then we'll come back
to us when that happens all right let's
read some
more Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim shout
out to BLM woke college students and
farle leftists thank you for revealing
to the world what we've been what we've
always known about you that you trash
human beings may you continue to show
your
yes I'm I'm I'm I'm you know a lot of
Democrats are coming out not right being
like there's that guy David Weissman I
respect respect what he tweeted he says
the right was right about black lives
matter yeah thank you for for for
recognizing that that's good seven right
direction Ryan Hunter says I've been
handed a life sentence on X for
advocating for the use of lethal force
in justifiable self-defense y'all won't
be seeing there seeing me there anymore
and my blue check money will be going to
the cast brew coffee now keep rocking
you know what we're going to do we're
we're going to make C Brew social media
we'll make the on the C Brew app you can
post your thoughts I'm kidding I thought
we say were going to make a blue check
mark Rose but blue check mark roast just
tastes like blueberries or whatever
Raymond g Stanley Jr says results are in
of the timcast IRL audience poll should
Palestine be the 51st state the winner
with 42% is no the second place at 38%
is WTF are you are you on
about
kalishnikov says so much for breaking
out of an open air prison I don't want
us to further any involvement however I
fully support Israel's scorched Earth in
Gaza I I don't you see that's a problem
so when Lindsey Graham goes on TV and
says we're in a religious War level the
place they're playing that message right
now for everyone in Gaza saying see this
is what they're going to do to you you
have to join us you have to do these
things that's how you perpetuate War if
Lindsey Graham had gone on TV and said I
this is a terrible tra Y what Hamas did
was was an atrocity they must be held
accountable and we will do everything we
can to protect those who are innocent
civilians that would have played
substantially better instead he's just
making making it all worse because these
people want war and they want war with
Iran you ever look at a map and you see
you see Iraq and Afghanistan and what's
right in the middle it's almost like we
were surrounding their country
wonderful cam says in the Bible talks
about Nations will surround Israel in
the end times crazy that it might happen
soon love your content guys keep keep it
the fight that's why someone super
chated us about the red heer yeah so I
looked it up and I was reading about it
like there have been people trying to
breed red heers and import them oh W
just just to like accelerate basically
do you get into the religious part of it
all like that do are you religious
yourself do you do you find the the the
story of of the apocalypse and well I'm
certainly interested in it yeah for sure
so what are you saying with the red heer
trying to breed well so there there it's
it's I I don't I'm not going to pretend
to know anything about this other than I
read one article and you need like 10
red heers a pure red heer with not a
single blemish must be sacrificed to
purify the Third Temple which and they
haven't seen one in thousands of years
and so what happens is they're they're
trying they keep breeding red heers yeah
and that it'll be born it'll go this
one's it and then it'll grow up and then
there will be like a few hairs that are
the wrong color like nope not pure great
it has to be inspected by numerous
Scholars and and rabbis to confirm not a
single blemish a perfect red heer and
it's not it's been thousands of years
since they've seen one yeah if they
genetically engineered one they're
trying they've been trying it's not
working that's crazy like there's always
there all like there's going to be a few
hairs that are the wrong color it's like
blemish yep some blemish somewhere a
little spot somewhere wow nothing you
can do about it yeah but this person
referring to is like the battle of
Armageddon and megiddo and the megiddo
valley and stuff like that if anyone
wants to look into it definitely do do
your due diligence because it's
crazy yeah where's oh super chats Eric
Miller says Tim how about making a
tribute blend for Casper where all the
proceeds go to a cause the Discord is
supporting once a month and we get
coffee yes perhaps it's it's it's not
super easy to set up um a blend and I
got to be completely honest they don't
make that much money that's just a
reality like we're we we want to do um
specific Blends for various
personalities like you're talking about
Alex Stein Prime Time grind 2x caffeine
and Sheamus coglin's uh you know Irish
coffee or whatever ever but like the
amount of money that would be made off
it is just it's not even worth it's it's
almost not even worth promoting
individually like that's that's the
problem it's like you know we're going
to do it anyway but I think based on
what it costs us to make what we make
from it and what the individual the like
the amount of money we make off each bag
it doesn't it can't compare to a normal
ad read so asking someone like Alex
Stein hey do it do an ad read for this
coffee and you'll get the profits or
whatever he would make more if he did a
normal ad pitch through any other
company cuz we just don't make that much
money off the coffee so buy more coffee
I suppose though if we sold all of it at
once it would be worth it but based on
like the amount that we sell per bag
it's not that much if we launched like
5,000 bags and sold them all in one week
that would definitely be worth it for
you know Alex or or Sheamus but I think
they're both interested anyway so we're
going to try and do stuff like that
sounds like once we franchise that
you'll start selling 5,000 bags of
wholesale is is is going to be big if we
can if we can start moving like 20 to
50,000 bags through a network of smaller
stores that's when you know people like
Alex are going to or or like like a
charity is really going to like get a
good return on this so that's what we're
looking at right now we're working with
Chef Andrew grul about the franchising
agreement and everything that we have to
do legally and then we're also looking
at wholesale and the big win obviously
is once you get a contract at a chain of
supermarkets you're good because now
you're like instantly moving thousands
of bags every week or something you know
a lot of people they go to the grocery
store there's like a coffee they'll grab
whatever there are some that I like and
some that I don't when I go to the
grocery store but for the most part we
only drink Casper now I got I got to be
honest like we we we formulated these
Blends M uh most of them some like
there's a Colombian it's Colombian but
uh for that reason I think obviously the
best coffee I've ever had that's good
because like I put it together I'm like
I'm mixing stuff and I'm like let's try
30% 30% and like here's what I like here
are the flavors that I like and then I'm
like this is the best coffee ever did
you do like the French roast and stuff
as well or those just like regular ones
the the French Colombian colan yeah it's
just like basic basic on right like the
the we get we get the beans imported
there's a we have a distributor that
they put it all together but like the
like Appalachia Knights Roberto Jor
those are Blends right stand your ground
is a blend so the stuff that we're
making is like a unique proprietary
specific thing that we put together well
French Ro is still good guys I like the
French roast I like pumpkin spice uh the
French roast and the Pumpkin Spice are
my least favorites out of all of them
yeah yeah definitely but Appalachia kns
is just wow that's my favorite coffee
stand your grounds all day but rise with
Roberto Jr sells the most and there's no
question it's because they people want
Roberto Jun it's a celebrity Factor you
that that brand power of you know
Roberto junr died he had a heart attack
and died suddenly our rooster man he's
our true influencer you know uhhuh yeah
it is crazy though that like even the
rooster is helping sell the product
Appalachian Knights has has no mask on
they just like it's just because we're
here which is Appalachia you know and
people like that's cool so it does sell
well and it's really good but people
want the rooster on the bag yeah they
want that rooster so I'm like we'll just
put more roosters on bags I guess well
cuz and all of the the birds at least as
far as I know all of them have names at
at least one point all of them did there
are so many now we have rb3 rb3 yeah
Roberto Junior's son his his air and uh
Dorothy right no D's been around for a
while who is Roberto Jr's mom uh that
was I believe that was Karina maybe she
should get a bag she died but in her
memory yeah had cancer yeah oh no but
she's the matriarch of this yeah so the
thing is about the original batch of
chickens we got it was in January and we
were warned by the farm that this is an
early and weak batch it's still cold out
and we were like no it's cool and
they've been sick in fact two of them
died right when we bought them they were
they were weak and sick and then Roberto
Jr was the first born of the original
batch and he was sick so it's like but
then we we brought in some diverse
genetics and we've mixed them all and
now they're they're all fairly robust so
you know good for the chickens good for
the chickens we got rb3 now looks just
like his dad but he's got white on his
wings and
body all right wett says Ben chapiro
pointed out that Hamas doesn't live by
Western morals we think it is insane and
wild that someone would be had babies
because of our morals Hamas wants the
eradication of the Jews my people that's
that's another thing that people don't
understand is that
if you look at the way Israel operates
it's operating under a very typical
Western moral standard but the the the
Palestinians do not have the ex the same
moral standard this is why the left
supports Palestine and the right tends
to support
Israel because you have on the left the
oppressed versus oppressor when we had
Max on the other day he was mentioning
that Israel has the power here and
therefore it's like okay that's like the
leftest moralist view right if we don't
have that I don't think power inherently
makes you wrong or evil yeah if
if the fighting between Israel if no one
was funding them and it was just War we
be well the war is going on again
because you've got war in Sudan and
Somalia how often are we talking about
that never the US has a vested military
interest in Israel Israel has become
more powerful and now the left is saying
look look they're oppressors and I'm
like well y'all are at War and one side
is getting better weapons I would like
it there to be no war but there's
there's look man when one side says we
want from the river to the Sea and the
other side is like please stop attacking
us you know what do you do you can make
land with volcanic magma by redirecting
it into the ocean and it'll cool down
and create more land mass yes and will
that get will they will they clone
Jerusalem
and at least they're like only nine
miles away the actual solution would be
like create a parallel mirror dimension
of an equal and opposite Jerusalem oh
like in the Pod put Jerusalem pod jar
Jerusalem yep and then it's like well
now which one's the real one I don't
know but you can have that one yeah yeah
yeah I'm not saying is innocent or we've
got the Moon I mean there's all kinds of
solutions we could just ship people into
space we're working on Mars underground
we haven't really talked much about the
underground lifestyle nobody wants to
live underground the problem is they're
all fighting over the Holy Land Subway
God what were you going to say something
Tim before that I I'm not saying
Israel's innocent yeah right people keep
saying look at isra yeah it's War right
that's it it's War I mean everybody's
Innocent but obviously everyone's
complicit everyone's involved if the
colonists who came to this country were
enslaved and caged by the Native
Americans and hundreds of years went by
and there was a minority population of
White European settlers who still lived
here the left would be like the poor
white people oh they're oppressed and
and mercilessly beaten yeah it's it's
it's it's the Marxist worldview of
oppressor versus oppress they're not I
said
that okay let's grab some more Super
chats here oh we got a stink bug flying
around uh oh oh there's so manying Lurch
685 says you guys are full of it crying
when Israelis chip a nail but you're
silent when Palestinians are massacred
in Mass complete hypocrisy occupied
people have the in alen inalienable
right to resist uh thank you for the
free
$10 um when Hamas broke out through of
the fencing and then started killing
civilians I think it's revealing that
you called that chipping a nail yeah so
your opinion is uh uh uh is is is
understood and uh I welcome you to give
more money to say it but we see through
what you what you're really saying like
dude it it is reasonable to come out and
be like hey I don't like what Israel is
doing with Gaza it's an open air prison
yes they Hamas should not be targeting
civilians it's bad for them
strategically politically and it's going
to cost them
dearly no you can't even say that okay
then spare me that that's why when I see
these leftists they're holding a sign
saying no more funding for Israel I'm
like what they're really saying is they
want Israel defenseless so they can
eradicate them right yeah that's why I I
can't stand that because it's like I'm
like opposed to 4 and8 for libertarian
reasons and like America reasons I don't
you know like what what's going on it's
not been Justified but these people are
like yeah I agree no funding for Israel
because they actually want to go and
start killing people
yeah we'll grab some more Super chats
Matthew reamp says what Tim is talking
about is called semantic shift my
favorite example of it is how the
original Old English meaning of silly
was blessed wow really I didn't know
that that's interesting and I believe
the word sink was created by Shakespeare
the kitchen sink huh there like a bunch
like invented a bunch of words
so many
words neglectful sausage says when Biden
said finish the job he met the
Crusades did the Christians start the
Crusades I was trying to remember uh yes
the Crusades were Christians going down
to recapture the holy land injur okay
when the Ottomans had it uh probably I
don't if the Ottoman Empire was like it
was exactly the thing but they're just
taking from whoever had at the time yeah
there's been a lot of them like I think
three or three or four Crusades there
are more there well they're jihads there
would be a crusade then a Jihad take it
back then a crusade to take it back then
a Jihad to take it back and yep that's
why this is not going to be sorted out
toly it's going to take a while Heath
Hansen says I know it's been suggested
before but you guys should read the
storm before the storm about the fall of
the Roman Republic the parallels to
today are striking love from the great
state of Iowa I mean honest question why
why can't the Palestinian people uh if
they are in an open air prison go to say
Jordan or Saudi Arabia or Egypt Egypt or
Lebanon why don't these countries want
to accept these these poor refugees who
are trapped in an open air prison
because the point is for them to be
trapped in open air prison right it's to
have that because they want the leverage
to make Israel look bad and attack
Israel and take over the point is taking
over Israel yeah at the end of the day
yeah at the end of the day so they need
so of course they're not going to want
to move those P those people into their
own countries and save countries exactly
oh here's a good one M says mine
Albright said it was worth it when
talking about half a million children
dying in Iraq based on lies so she's a
terrorist right yes yeah absolutely yes
uh uh no question for us I don't know
what you think here we agree um uh
Barack Obama should be criminally
charged he should be retroactively
impeached and then criminally charged
for the killing of anoir alaki and
abduraman alaki make your arguments
about anoir being a Jihadi and fighting
against America fine but I'm not we're
not we're not going anywhere with Abdul
Raman if if you accidentally kill
somebody that's manslaughter Barack
Obama ordered a drone strike that killed
an American citizen lock him up you want
to complain about Donald Trump order
ordering a Commando right in Yen which
killed an 8-year-old American Girl
absolutely investigation get the
evidence you prove it bound A Reasonable
Doubt lock him up impeach him all that
jazz the the the I will always isue the
clarification the Drone strike in Yemen
we know it's been confirmed and admitted
to and the Commando raid in Yemen while
confirmed we don't have the same hard
evidence of the killing of the
8-year-old girl those are allegations as
of right now I think they should be
investigated 100% no free passes no free
passes for American war crimes
so uh yeah you want to complain about
the Iraq War bro that's what we are all
on about the Iraq War was disgusting we
shouldn't have been there or Afghanistan
the US really just wants to get that
cheap gas don't they and they won't
build nuclear power how about that
anyway yett says special force have been
offered to help rescue hostages since
some of the hostages are American
citizens that's right and what they're
saying is right now it's Logistics and
finance they're saying no actual boots
on the ground but I fear that it could
get to that degree because it's what
they do it's what they do when people
get
kidnapped Winston Alexander says
shouldn't Pro palestin American
protesters also care about the Americans
killed or taken hostage also shouldn't
we evacuate Palestinian Americans from
Gaza war is hell and we are funding both
sides war is hell and we are funding
both sides good point yeah yep
especially if it's true that weapons
from Ukraine and Afghanistan are leaking
into into uh Gaza you know where we are
getting that money from is the C the
central bank so really it's the central
bank that's funding it and they're
making money on it because they're
getting interest back on their on their
loans Lurch says I effing told you guys
Lurch is also the person who said that
the terror attack on civilians and the
murder of civilians was a chipping was
chipping a nail yeah same dude oh well
hold on Lurch if you think that a bunch
of dudes storming into a music festival
in a bunch of uh small towns and
massacring people is chipping a nail
then you clearly have no issue with what
Israel does in Gaza because you know got
him that's stubbing a toe right yeah
yeah why do you care Oh Palestine
stubbed their toe oh like come on man I
I I can't stand the the people who are
like like you we recognize it's war and
war is bad we want there to be no war
but you're not winning any favors from
people who were born after the start of
it by celebrating the killing of
civilians sorry that's what I was saying
to Max the other day I'm like okay Hamas
is they feel their only strategy and
only tactic is military and the
kidnapping of civilians then they've
lost internationally and they are
resigned to their prison cuz the way I
see it is if there's somebody locked in
jail and they're screaming I'm innocent
I'm innocent let me go I shouldn't be
here and then you're like man I don't
know I don't maybe you are that's
horrifying if you are and then he breaks
out one day runs full speed towards some
random 20-year- old woman and
mercilessly beats her to death I'll be
like y'all should probably be in prison
yeah but then if the prison guards start
Exterminating all the prison rers then
you're like whoa who's the bad guy now
well it's more like what the prisoners
do they were like causing ruckuses and
like which one of them are evil we don't
know but we're going to let this one out
and he turned out to be one of the bad
ones and then you're saying that a bunch
of prisoners are making weapons and
shivs and guns like chaos in the prison
and then they break out and start
killing people so the prison guards
start shooting at them I'm like uh-huh
they they if so like what happen is the
prisoners some of the prisoners break
out they they kill a bunch of people so
the prison CS kill those or they maybe
not then what they turn their eyes on
all the prisoners that are still behind
bars what they do to them cuz that's
what that's those are people in Gaza
right
now prisoners come over here if you
don't want to be imprisoned you're
implying that solu you're implying that
Israel looks at Gaza and says let's just
kill people no that's what you said it's
like it's like in the way kind of is
that Israel is targeting the the the
military and weapons Depot the Hamas
Depot that where they're where they're
storing weapons and and their base of
operations that's the argument and you
can argue that Israel takes a wide
respect to what that means and there's a
lot of collateral damage but the
implication would be that after a bunch
of dudes put a bunch of weapons together
in the in the in the hospital as a
staging ground then broke out and
started killing people the guards
started opening fire on the hospital
area and there were there were there
were workers and stuff in there who got
hit as well and they were innocent this
is called war and it's called collateral
damage and it's why war is is BS and
it's why we hate War because collateral
damage always happens I don't know I
don't know what to say man my point is
is if they were really like Hey we're in
an open air prison and they broke out
maybe they would run from the prison
maybe maybe they would run to the area
area where they were safe and outside of
the prison so the argument about them
being in a prison I think is nonsense
because a prison is something you break
out of an escape from no the argument is
the land that Israelis live on 75 years
ago was theirs and they want it back
okay well now you're at War that's not
about being in prison that's about you
wanting to go to war that's why when
they break out they go to war so the
left lies about everything they're in an
open air prison trying to escape they're
they're marching peacefully I'm like bro
if they were trying to escape from
prison they'd run Max BL last night was
saying that they would I don't i' never
heard this before they they would put
their weapons away and walk barehanded
to the gates and be shot and killed on
their way they get shot in the legs get
shot and they're like well if we can't
petition with our with our hands like
open then what that was that was hard to
hear and and I suppose the issue is
that's the Palestinian argument the
Israeli argument is probably they
actually did have weapons they were
hiding them not every one of them did
but a leftist tactic that we see in the
United States they will call for a
public peaceful protest what they're
really trying to do is build body mass
numbers so that the people with weapons
can go and hide in the crowd exactly
yeah so when they were like we were
marching peacefully Israel's probably
like dude like one in 10 had a gun and
they were planning on sneaking through
the crowd and shooting at people it's
it's their only weapon is international
public opinion to be like no look what
they're doing to us look they killed all
the children that we threw at them to
kill y exactly they use his Shields it's
their only weapon I mean obviously the
weapons not they murder people in
terrorist attack but their most powerful
weapon is international opinion and
bleeding heart Western liberal
governments Joseph metler says Jordan
took in 500,000 of them and they caused
many problems Jordan killed 30,000 in
one summer and force them all back uh
force them all back to Israel wow I
didn't not know that well I don't know
so back check was there also what's the
number of how many Palestinians had
Israeli work pieas 30,000 I think don't
know something like that every day they
go back and forth they get to work in
Israel they go back yeah I don't know I
mean it wasn't well there are there are
people of of like there Arab Israelis
who live yeah of course isra Christian
Israelis yeah and Christian right
certainly mosques and churches in Israel
there's like 400 you know it's a lot
it's not not a little amount and there's
tons of Asylum seekers in Israel from
Palestine who are gay yeah who apply for
asylum in Israel right because they'll
get killed in Gaza for Palestine yeah if
anyone hasn't seen uh Alex's uh Gaye for
pal thing in play of the day was
hilarious it's pretty good all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net
and uh you can buy anywhere you get your
books that's awesome uh I'm Hannah CL
brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
at hcbo and on Instagram at hana. guys
thank you so much this has been a cool
conversation this was I agree uh thanks
for coming in also I the conversation
tends towards like down a drain it's all
going in One Direction right now so it's
cool that we have to talk about the book
a little bit great to meet you man yeah
likewise same to you I'm Ian crosslin
I'll catch you guys probably tomorrow
have a nice day you mean in 3 minutes
I'll catch you in 3 minutes at
timcast.net
to mention uh last couple days my one
year anniversary of being on the show oh
wow sick yeah I'm super excited about it
anyways you can follow me at surge.com
on Twix and Etc I know it's crazy feel
like it's been a year been a year I
found a I found I put on my coat cuz
it's like getting C out and I reached my
pocket and found a receipt from March of
2022 and I was like oh my God anyways
guys yeah cheers we'll see you in the
after show all right everybody we'll see
you all over at timcast.net